What's it called again?
What's the gym called?
Verde Valley.
Brazilian Jujitsu.
So Verde Valley Bjj and what?
What town is that in?
Old Town.
Cottonwood and Arizona.
So you essentially like a invested in,
built a gym out there,
so you'd have a place to train
basically.
Yeah.
That's such a smart move.
It's kind of what you have to do,
right?
Yeah.
Otherwise you'd have to drive hours to
mega tons down south.
There's a bunch of places down there,
but they're just.
It's a two hour drive.
There's also Ted Osbourne.
I was branches.
Jitsu has an academy there.
When you decide like where are you going
to live?
When you decide where you're going to
like decide to spend all your time,
like do you ever go,
what the fuck am I doing in the middle
of nowhere in Arizona?
I'm maintaining peace of mind and I
remind myself of that right away.
So that's like a central.
It's planned out in the sense that just
that,
that isolation a little bit just to be
able to unplug and reset.
I think just my introvert nature,
I need.
I need that time.
I need that.
I need that introspection.
I need that moment.
Yeah,
because of you,
you are kind of an introvert,
but you're also kind of an extrovert.
I mean,
you're the lead singer of tool.
it's not like,
I mean you can only be so introverted
and do what you do,
so you have to kind of fluctuated
between Alex,
but I need to recharge.
I need to unplug and go back and
recharge and that I can go back out and
do that.
A lot of people never figured that out.
Right?
They just kind of burn.
They burned the fuck out.
How'd you figure out to not do that?
Um,
first couple of years of being in La,
realize it was just such an energy sap.
I needed to actually literally go
someplace where there were very few
people.
Yeah.
That's the move,
right?
God,
I always keep
thinking I should do that.
Every time I go to some small town,
I'm like,
this is probably the way to live.
Just like know the people around you
live around a few thousand people,
you know,
have a grocery store that can backfire
too.
Oh,
totally.
Yeah.
Small town,
small town,
big town drama.
It ends up being the same thing,
but you actually,
it's not a stranger yelling at you.
It's your neighbor.
Well,
I think the small town dramas better if
there's a college in town for some
reason.
Right?
Like those places like boulder or
there's a bunch of cities like that.
Bozeman,
Montana is a good example.
There's these places that are like,
they're not big,
but the university somehow another
balances out the intellectual vibe of
the town.
I could see that.
Yeah,
like bolder.
Yeah.
Boulder.
I wonder
what is like now in the height and fury
of Social Justice Warrior online
activism.
I wonder if boulder has gotten weird.
I haven't been bashed because that
replaces kind of ramped up that shit
over the last few years.
So you get me okay.
On this right to do some beautiful.
Can you hear me okay?
Connor Sanomat,
he's got conor mcgregor standing right
in front of him for advice.
So if anything south connor
doesn't have is fuck you pinstripe suit
on though.
He's got his fuck you attitude in his
fists right now.
Did you see the press conference?
No,
I.
that's one of those.
I was trying to find what's the edit to
like watch that thing rather than this.
There's so much streaming going on.
I had no idea what I was looking for the
best for all.
You want to see as connor talking a
little bit of little bit of floyd
mayweather responding,
but connor talking does Dana White's
video feed?
You could watch on d.
We can put it up right now.
You want to.
You want to listen to it.
Why not go to Dana White's instagram
profile and then once you go to his
instagram profile,
go to the video that's playing in his
youtube.
There's like a link like on his
instagram,
but ca connor's hilarious man.
He's fucking hilarious and he's laughing
and having a great time and floyd seem
like he seemed a little rattled by like
how confident this guy is when they were
going face to face is standing off with
each other.
Yeah,
give me some volume when they get face
to face
it.
Go back to that.
Listen to them talk some shit.
I'm going to go before that.
He is a zoom anymore.
Go before that.
There you go.
Right there.
Right there,
right?
It can't even afford it anymore.
Damn.
He is
his little.
His little head.
I'm going to knock them out inside four
rounds.
Wait until they get in front of me
each other and they start John
and August mcgregor line.
I've been on the pins.
Busy as fuck.
You know.
Let's get this.
Let's have fun.
Thank you so much everybody.
Appreciate it.
And Floyd Mayweather get in front of
each other.
So scoot.
Scoot ahead to inhuman.
Flug is floyd gets up and says a bunch
of Shit and bunch of other people say a
bunch of Shit.
Floyd.
Look really stupid.
Backup a little bit.
Can you see floyd hold up his truck is
check for $100.
Million.
Look at back it up,
back it up.
You motherfuckers out of fight or flight
test.
Shit.
That's in a tax man and I'm attached.
Show Shit.
You're going on your face or you're
going on your bed.
Now let him use his show up.
You just show up and I'm going to do the
rest face to face anyway.
This
is a real fight.
You're dead already.
Oh,
this is amazing.
Do your hands hurt when it gets cold?
Because Floyd had a bunch of hand
surgeries.
He goes,
you got brittle hands.
The hands hurt when it gets cold.
They hurt when it's cold.
Yeah,
I have no,
I,
I don't know enough about boxing to have
any clue.
All I can look at it from a distance is,
is floyd's older?
He's slightly smaller.
He's also the greatest defensive boxer
of all time.
Right?
Like literally of all time.
And Michael Jordan was arguably one of
the best basketball player,
but put him back in the game today.
You have a flood?
Has it been now for that long?
I mean he's still relevant.
I mean he's only been a couple of years.
I think it was two years since his last
fight against Andre Berto.
Was it two years and then before that?
The pack?
Yeah.
I'll fight,
you know,
look,
he's not as crime.
So yeah.
I'm saying,
you know,
so that was,
that was my look.
That's what you look at,
you and go age,
reach all that stuff,
size watching what happened to mcgregor
up against dss,
having that wasn't really ready for that
larger dude to hit him.
Yeah.
Um,
is that the equation?
But then,
you know,
Mcgregor's no joke.
So He's,
you know,
he but Kenny handle a guy who's done
this a hundred times times.
He's done it more than 100 timing.
Floyd's grew up doing it.
The thing about floyd is I think you
have an idea of what you can do to women
until you get inside the ring with them
and then you realize how good he is.
His defense is just on another level.
He's just in a completely different zone
all by himself.
His movement,
the way he's able to figure out what
you're going to do with the way he
processes your movement,
throws it into his boxing computer.
And then before you know,
and he's catching you before you even
know what you're doing.
He's just a wizard band when it comes to
boxing.
The thing is,
connor is a way bigger guy.
He's younger.
He's way stronger.
I mean physically stronger.
Not just in terms of like punching
power,
he's way stronger with punching power,
but he's also like stronger physically.
Like if he gets a hold of floyd and
starts manipulating them.
I'm very curious to see what like his,
his trainer John Kavanagh is a very,
very smart guy.
I know he's also worked with Paulie
Malignaggi who's a world champion and
one of the best boxing commentators in
the business.
He's helping connor.
It's going to be interesting.
You know on paper you would have to say
floyd as a massive advantage,
but all this shit talking.
Whereas on a man that's,
that's a different kind of shit.
Talking to employees ever experienced
and had that.
He's got a guy telling him,
I can kill you easy.
He's like,
got a guy telling you that this is a
real fight.
You're dead.
You're dead in 20 knows he's right.
He knows he's right.
Floyd fucking knows it.
If Floyd,
he let his ego get crazy.
Let's have an MMA match.
Let's go ahead and have an MMA match
that he said.
That's it.
He's a dead man.
He's fighting them in the octagon there
and with four ounce gloves to.
Yeah,
he said that he's ridiculous.
Let them use elbows.
Let them you just give them one more
weapon and you're fucked.
You tie up and you want to do this and
over the top comes an elbow and your
fucking legs give out on you.
One given one more weapon.
Give him knees.
Knees are leg kicks.
We can't we.
It's crazy.
Like I just think connor,
I just think you need to calm down a
little bit and give him some beautiful.
Don't give him any space.
Just kidding.
A little bit of space stuff showed up to
this little space.
Just Space Joe.
That is A.
I'm the guy who makes those a bad
motherfucker.
How do you pronounce his name?
Plastics.
Plastic.
Plastic stuff now,
but the gentleman who makes her fall
along Tran,
I believe he's a bad motherfucker.
Pretty amazing.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Right?
So,
so accurate.
The big.
You've seen the beginning.
Where's Biggie that we had to move them?
We were doing something here.
Look at the big one and the Tupac.
One guy's a wizard man.
That's my,
that's me.
Who's that guy?
Um,
but look,
it's a spectacle.
You know what happens,
happens.
Yeah.
I hold back.
This is what it's all
about.
Oh yeah.
It's not like whatever happens in the
ring.
Yeah.
Whatever.
That's gonna sell.
Yeah.
It's going to sell.
They're going to charge 100 bucks for
paper review.
Her charging charge.
Who you're not going to pay,
you're going to pay.
How dare you?
Everyone listens.
Pain.
If you've got 100 bucks you can fuck it.
Have 10 people over.
It's 10 bucks,
but you wouldn't pay 10 bucks to see
that you're out of your fucking mind.
I paid my screen.
The screen at my house is so awesome
that it's actually,
it's worth like I had to.
I have to literally have to pay a
thousand dollars to watch it.
So if you want to come over,
it's 100 bucks.
You have to pay a thousand dollars to
watch when you mean.
Oh,
he's got a thing.
All right.
See what he's doing?
Yeah.
Do you have like one of those,
100 inch led or lcd?
What it is it led or LCD or led now?
Right.
I saw one at the,
uh,
at the store the other day at best buy.
They have like 100 inch TV.
Like that is fucking crazy.
You look at that thing.
It's almost too,
too good.
Yeah.
No,
no,
don't do that.
Are you filming?
You're filming a lot of Shit.
You do it in four k?
I don't know.
I mean all the video stuff.
We do a when that the one,
that red camera first came out,
we had some friends that were using math
and they were using the Canon for
awhile.
I'm just filming on and I don't know
what they're filming on.
I just know that over the last five
years just insane.
Just jump in technology for filming.
It's been amazing not having to have
like dude with like lights and some guy
with a on a dolly.
No,
it's like the guy's a small,
tiny little thing.
Tiny thing doing insane,
insane work.
They have trail cams now that are in
four k,
so like when they're looking for animals
in the woods,
they put these cameras up on trails and
they capture motion capture and then
they'd take video four k video and it's
fucking amazing low light video and they
showed the difference.
There was something I was looking at
yesterday and show the difference
between state of the art two years ago
versus state of the art today and the
exact same location,
exact same time and it's crazy.
Like you could see everything crystal
clear.
It's hd video from a tree,
a little box tied to a tree and it looks
like a fucking movie.
That's pretty awesome.
Dude.
You're missing out on that hide out in
the middle of nowhere,
Arizona.
Not really though.
That's the thing.
It's not like when you're hiding out
there,
you're still connected.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's.
We just finished our a two greenhouses
there were planting them this next week,
so I've got full on greenhouses on one
of the sites.
Are you totally off the grid?
Not off the grid,
no,
but I mean that would be,
that'd be nice.
I think that's the goal.
Feel like you can be right with solar.
Yeah.
And,
and I've waited on solar just to see
again,
Canberra's were what they were two years
ago to today.
How are the solar panels catching up?
Because I know that that technology is
insane.
Now,
do you know what Elon Musk is doing?
He's making solar powered powered roof
tiles,
right?
So your whole roof is like a giant solar
generator,
which,
and those things are great.
So all you know,
I'm the kind of guy that wakes up,
I want,
I want to see.
Okay,
once he's put those in place,
how do they do against tile?
A hail.
How did they do sun?
How.
That's a good point.
I want to see how those things last
because I'm not going to invest all that
money and,
and a roof tiles.
If all of a sudden they find it a year
that they,
that crack under Arizona Sunshine.
You get crazy storms in Arizona to do
near the place where they get typhoons.
Is that,
is it typhoons and monsoons?
Monsoons.
Yeah.
Science students.
We just started seeing evidence like
yesterday we got hailed and like a
little dabble of monsoon yesterday.
Yeah,
like sometimes like people think of
Arizona,
the thing of the desert,
but there's a lot of different terrain
in Arizona.
Yes.
And you guys,
when it rains you guys get fucking
pounded on,
right?
What is this gym?
The hail test for the tesla roof tiles.
A lifetime warranty on them.
Boom.
Oh,
it took it like a champ.
And what are those other two bitches?
Yeah,
the regular traditional roof tiles.
Oh,
they're regular roof tiles.
So the Tesla panels are fucking better
bench 100 mile an hour impact.
Wow.
Well then there you have it.
I'm in.
Yeah,
because that's what I've been waiting
for it to see if they can get this,
that technology up.
I'm just waiting for Elon Musk to run
the world.
I'm like,
Dude,
you're on point.
Keep it up.
Yeah,
just make roof tiles and cars and just
keep it up.
Yeah.
Ben,
you know,
I don't know that being completely off
the grid is.
I think it's an option for some people.
There's just too many people.
For you to be actually,
you know,
completely unplug and be isolated.
Yeah.
I don't want to be comedy ones.
Don't know it doesn't work.
Was going to be trade.
He's turned into a big fuck fest.
Right.
It's like the one that you'd be like the
leader and you just want to bang and
everybody's wife.
I don't know.
From experience that you're.
That you're aware of a let now.
Yes.
It is what happens,
right?
I don't see.
I think that like off the grid,
like in terms of like non reliance,
but connectivity in terms of like being
able to figure out what's going on in
the world.
Yeah.
That,
that,
that's a,
that's a reasonable goal I think,
but I think even even being off the
grid,
I feel like,
uh,
you can get to a certain point in
today's society where you can be
unplugged from your,
your power and your water,
but somebody's going to come for your
water,
so he's going to come for.
There's various places around the United
States where they come after you for
growing your own food on your land.
Do they really?
Yeah.
There's weird stuff everywhere like
that.
Like what?
What kind of regulations or do they have
against?
It ended up using.
They would probably justify it in terms
of your house.
Your House is zoned residential,
not Oh,
not agriculture or you're,
you,
you're not allowed to use the city water
to water your garden.
I've actually heard this before.
I've heard people get in trouble with
that before.
It's a,
it's just another level of government
control.
Do you think that doing that,
it's just like,
no,
you're not,
you're not a prepper.
Right?
I'm a prepper,
but slightly but not.
Not In that Alex Jones sort of way.
No,
not that.
Not that bananas.
Uh,
I think just being prepared and
understanding that eventually the,
there'll be an interruption and the
water that comes to you and the food
that gets to just understanding how to
grow food is not being a prepper.
No,
it's wise.
It's like having a lot of boxes checked
off.
We just.
And it also doesn't it feel good.
Like I'm sure I know that you love your
wine.
I mean,
it's got to feel good when you have a
glass of the wine that you've grown and
created and worked so hard on and it
just established this perfect time of
keeping in the barrels and you know,
I'm sure there's got to be like massive
satisfaction to that.
Absolutely.
Because you know,
it spirals out into all these other,
other areas of understanding again,
how to,
how to grow your own food.
You start,
you start talking to and communicating
with people that you wouldn't normally
talk to like Republican guys now talking
to the Liberal Democrat guy and the,
and the,
and this religion is talking to that
religion and you know,
there's all these economic,
religious,
political lines get blurred because in
that moment,
talking about growing a thing and
sustaining a local community,
a lot of those things tend to go away.
Just turn this thing off and get back to
understanding what it's going to take to
make you know,
make these exchanges and do these
activities.
You start to really feel connected with
people rather than this weird divisive
crap that goes on in the world.
Yeah,
I think there's definitely like we need
to figure out how to spend more time
just having a regular normal day to day
conversations because it seems to me
like people are worse at it than they
ever been before.
People interrupt people more than like,
they're not good at like listening and
talking because I think people are so
accustomed to communicating with people
through devices.
It's almost like we're were rusty were
rusty on how we talk to people because
we don't do it that much.
Like how often do you call someone on
the phone?
Not that you and I have maybe never had
a phone call.
Maybe one phone conversations always
text and kind of all my friends.
If someone calls me up,
it's like,
what's everything?
Okay.
Yeah.
Like what's wrong?
No,
I don't use that thing for talking to
somebody.
I don't use this.
Don't use this to talk to people because
the technology to me still isn't where
it should be because I'll be in the
middle of making a point with somebody
and the phone call will drop and we have
to start over and so he got mad because
I just,
that's why I usually text her email
because I can get the whole thought down
and then if we want to talk about
summing up some details it I'll say I'll
call
you from landline.
So I'll actually call people from.
I'll find a landline,
you know?
Have you heard of those?
They don't even have them anymore.
The red red around illegal right around
the same time as the cassette.
I send a raven.
That's what I do.
I got some dope ravens.
They're super smart.
You just got to leave like pineapple in
the and that's what they like to go
right to the pineapple take.
They're a little message.
What's up?
See this today.
Oh Jesus Christ
to scientists make teleportation
breakthrough,
but that's in the New York Post.
They also did an article about how
Travis Browne and Ronda Rousey are
fading losers.
Like it was the most ruthless article.
That is a great.
It's a great argument for not living in
a condensed population and some of the
articles in New York tabloid papers,
like they're so fucking mean.
Yeah.
Just something about like being in the,
like an island,
like Manhattan where.
But he stopped in there where people
just get super shitty with each other
and they find it okay to do so.
Yeah.
So what does this teleportation.
It's saying that it's teleporter to
photon from Earth to space,
like 50 miles in this space.
That's not exactly what happened.
They transported the information of the
Proton,
which is also,
it's equally important because they can
send out a fax to somebody again.
Space.
Wow.
Mit saying it.
So in sending a Photon,
is that like one step to sending light?
Yeah,
take the first step to say like it made
it like a carbon copy of it.
It's virtually identical.
It's like an identical twin of it.
So
it could be that,
that,
you know,
those kinds of newspapers are very
similar to what we're seeing with
facebook as far as the immediate
feedback.
And then they adjust the article and
adjust the,
the headline to not only make money from
clicks,
but also to manipulate what you were
thinking about a particular subject so
they can adjust your vote purchasing
patterns of those kinds of things.
So you know these click bait things.
That could have been a word in that
title that they know people like you
love to see.
So they got you clicking on it even
though there might be nothing in the
article.
There's a lot of that,
right?
You see like purposely deceptive article
headings.
So they did,
they rope you in and you're like,
what?
What are they doing?
But even doing that,
like are they talk well,
what happens?
Your original Photon,
the original photon remains present in
the original location.
It's a first step in some quantum
physics type deal proving that it can
actually happen.
Versus like just being a theory as far
as I understood.
I listened to a one minute video where I
talked to my buddy about this buy,
are you buying any of this?
Fuck all that.
Fuck all them.
Anywhere in that dorm.
One point you and your Fox on you and
your Proton,
one foot in your fucking proton.
Yeah.
I don't understand what they're.
So does that
mean like one day they'll have a jamie
vernon on a space holodeck in Arizona
and they'll zoom you up to space,
but then you'll still be here.
It's hard to say.
I don't think that that's what they're
doing with it.
I think this means more like they can
send the packets of information without
needing fiber or Wifi or anything like
that.
I think that's the first possible use of
it.
I think it's a matter of time before we
start duplicating things that we
shouldn't be duplicating.
You know,
like a whole human beings like how many
deranged monarchs are going to get a
hold of this like way before anybody
else is trillionaire dudes and they're
gonna spend a shit ton of money to have
copies of them and just make a bunch of
this.
What if it's just a heath ledger's the
joker who is actually putting this out
and he's figured out a way to get all of
those beginner people to jump on this
spaceship.
That goes nowhere and he's giggling
somewhere.
See,
I always say we feel like we were always
one invention that we don't see coming
away from ruining everything.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I agree.
It could be,
it could be exactly.
This kind of thing.
This,
this algorithmic.
You going down a rabbit hole in this,
a narcissistic feedback on what you want
to see and then it tells,
tells you what you want to hear and then
it gets you to buy what you want to buy.
But like the thing you want to buy might
be this rabbit hole of,
of leveling the playing field for
everybody.
Yeah.
It might be wants.
Um,
yeah.
I think the only.
Yeah.
Is there a way out of that?
Um,
doesn't seem like it.
Well,
I think the other,
the way out of it is his understanding
that the things you're being told here,
this has nothing to do with mastership,
if that makes sense.
The phone,
just media things.
You're reading on your social media
pages.
This has nothing to do with a guy.
I read all those articles.
Well that's not necessarily mastership.
That's not.
You're going to a master who has,
who has spent all this time doing a
thing or researching a thing and
master's degree in a thing,
and then you go to this class,
you take the time,
the effort it takes to get to that place
at every step along the way is a new
level of revelation or some kind of
epiphany of understanding of,
oh,
that's why we did this,
and then now I can understand that and
educate yourself,
so destroying,
destroying an entire base of ignorance
and knee jerk reaction,
clicking on links and being fed
horseshit.
It almost has to be like a,
a conscious effort on each individual to
step back and go,
I hate that trump supporter.
I hate that hillary or a Bernie
supporter because of the things I've
been told and the things I believe that
had been fed back to me.
Um,
what if,
then this is the hardest step,
I think for most people.
What if I am completely wrong about all
of it?
So how do I empty my vessel,
opened my mind,
and try to figure backtrack on what the
truth is?
Is this person really that much
different than me?
Are these people that much different?
Did they grow up with a bad you bad set
of poison in their system that I grew up
with a bad poison in my system?
I don't know.
So I don't know if there's any way out
of it because the solution I'm talking
about requires a lot of introspection,
a self evaluation,
and a lot of,
uh,
being more open than most people are
willing to be.
Do you know why?
I think there's a way out of it because
there's a lot of people like you saying
that I know a lot of people that are
saying that now and it seems like a
message that's being broadcast by a
bunch of people that have gone through
the gauntlet of life and had a bunch of
trials and tribulations and they reached
this point where they kind of have an
understanding of what it's taken them to
get there.
And a lot of people like you have this
desire to relay this information and
people are listening and there's a lot
of other people that are saying the same
thing that have also gone through their
own separate trials and I think it's a,
it's a more prevalent message than I've
ever heard in my life.
And I'm almost 50.
I'll be 50 next month and I feel like in
my life I've never.
August 11th.
Really?
Yup.
What's your birthday is a 12.
Get the fuck Outta here,
bitch.
Uh,
my,
my son's birthday's the fifth.
My wine making buddies is the eighth
crazy.
I went in and out of the army the first
week of August.
We're basically all in the same
fraternity basically,
except for me.
I'm on areas.
What's a girl's thing?
It's not a fraternity.
What is it called?
Sorority.
Yeah.
We're in the same sorority.
Oh my God.
Was the same month.
Are you going?
Just the new ge?
Yeah.
I think more people are talking about
though,
man.
I think it's going to be not going to be
for everybody,
but I think there's way more people that
are trying to do better with their life,
do better with their mind,
do better with themselves.
It's a,
it's a very,
very common thing.
So much so there's a lot of criticisms
about the various methods and people
kind of losing sight and then there's
like,
there's a bunch of bullshit artists that
are capitalizing on this idea as well
and they're not really doing it,
but they're pretending they're doing it
and they're talking about it,
but they're not really an action.
But you can kind of see those guys
always look a little doughy.
They always look a little,
you know,
they're not really doing it,
but they're talking about people love
talking about shit.
They don't really do like some of my
friends that,
uh,
they'll talk about writing comedy way
more than they actually write comedy.
Like Judd apatow said that he said like,
don't fucking talk about writing just
right.
I think he's right.
Nice one.
Right?
I mean,
isn't it the same thing?
It's like there's a fine line between
inspiring,
discussing and then sort of analyzing
with people that you respect and trust
and like and then actually doing the
work.
Yeah,
and I think part of it is literally
working.
I think I'm getting your hands dirty in
the soil,
like find a as a star.
It's just think of it as therapy.
Whatever money you're spending on a
therapist,
take take that time and go find a
community garden.
Just we'd
just go in there and plant some,
find some carrots,
do something to just kind of like unplug
and touch dirt and do a thing and
reconnect with that cycle.
If you can reconnect with that cycle of
life in some level,
you start to really understand what,
what's more important.
You know,
some people,
some people have kids that helps them
kind of reground themselves and redirect
and focus their energies.
Um,
some people will just find,
you know,
find gardening in that way.
But this is,
this is not this,
this is supposed to be a convenience.
This is just me trying to talk to you
from a distance and every.
But as far as the information you're
getting off of this thing and forms of
social media,
there's a lot of poise and there's a lot
of misdirect.
There's a lot of crap in there and you
have to kind of fight through it and
literally go eat a garden.
Yeah,
I think just think you're definitely
right.
I think doing that as good.
I also think doing difficult things is,
is good.
I think that's one of the reasons why
you're so drawn to Jujitsu and the
hardest thing I've ever done in my life.
It's the hardest thing that it's the,
it's the most.
It's,
you know,
I'm getting no snowflakey be here.
Um,
but it's just,
it's,
uh,
it's not something that you are handed.
You have to do the work to get it.
And I had so many injuries over the
years and it's so much distance from
this thing and I'm such a stubborn prick
that I'm,
I have,
I've started a thing,
I'm going to finish this thing.
Uh,
so that's Kinda where I'm at with
Jujitsu and it's not,
it's not something that you can be
handled.
Well,
you know,
someone's legit when they get a fucking
hip surgery and then the back on the mat
four months later,
that is first of all ridiculous and not
advisable,
but admirable at the same time.
It took me,
it took me a while to lose the weight.
I was gaining weight before the hip
surgery because I just couldn't move as
well as I wanted to.
Um,
obviously,
I mean it was completely destroyed hip.
No,
no cushion in there.
And uh,
and then the recovery was,
and then I was on the row,
which is like one of the worst ways to
recover from anything you're trying to
recover from being there in the moment.
But the thing I did finally found my
rhythm because I think last time we
talked,
I talked about how it's hard to train on
the road because I've got this thing I
got to do with at night.
Finding those guys,
finding the black belts that understand
the low,
low impact flow role,
uh,
putting threads together.
Just doing simple a positional drills,
all those things.
Now I've been able to,
like I,
you know,
I trained with Dave and Dan Camereo,
Henry Akins,
Rodrigo comes down,
touch flocks,
comes down.
I've been able to train with a lot of
people on the road that's amazing.
May Not be folk.
We find our,
we find our,
our right before sound check and you
know,
but it has to be people that trust us to
be people that have an understanding of
I'm not here to do this,
I'm here to do the same music.
Yeah.
This is just something that helps you
get to that.
Yeah.
So it's,
I'm just chipping away at that purple
belt,
trying to get to that next level.
Yeah.
I feel like I'm in my opinion,
drills or like one of the most important
things that people don't like to do is
this.
It's just one of those things where it's
Jujitsu,
like rolling and sparring.
It's so fun that people just want to get
right in there.
We'll just roll it.
Let's just roll.
And so you just kind of do it,
but the real work is done in the
drilling.
If you can't do it slow,
you can't do it fast,
especially if you don't understand it,
understand what it is you're supposed to
be doing,
and if you have a good part,
a training partner,
role player to help you and he's giving
you the exact position that you're,
that you're trying to train.
If he got one of those pricks,
that's like blue belt,
purple belt,
garlic,
no miss going to church,
I'm going to adjust this position to no,
that's not what you're,
that's not what you're here for.
Your troubles are important,
but like dead drills are important to
where a person just,
you just roll,
just roll through the technique with
them.
Right?
Yeah,
I mean it's like I've always found it
really interesting how many people like
find it sort of,
uh,
in,
in their life.
And it becomes like almost like a
replacement for religion and a lot of
ways it comes,
like this grounding thing for them.
Yeah,
I can see that.
Yeah.
I mean it's just,
it seems like the real difficult things,
whether it's Jujitsu or whatever you're
into.
You know,
I have a buddy that's into ultra
marathons.
That's his thing,
like it's just like pushy.
His body to run these crazy distances
becomes like this weird sort of like
centering threatened his life because he
knows it's so fucking difficult that all
the other things get easier.
Okay.
You know?
Yeah.
That's kick and run.
That's,
that's good for him.
I'll let him do that.
But you said that some people can run
with a hip replacement?
Yeah,
I've heard that there's some guys that
they'll go in every couple of years and
have the,
the actual pad of Ithaca silicone pad or
something that they're just.
They just cut them open.
They're like small incision.
Pop it out,
pop the hip out.
I guess so.
I guess during the surgery they go in
from the front.
Mike.
I went from the front so that you know
my leg was laying across my head while
they're in there digging my you.
So it's a full on scoping out the the
hip.
I'm sawing,
sawing off the hip,
the leg,
the femur bone,
putting a spike down the middle of your
femur with a ball on top,
and then putting it back in and then
waking you up about an hour later going,
let's go for a walk.
Oh my God.
How many?
How many inches is the spike?
A spike that goes into the ball?
I think it's like.
It's like about 20 Irish inches.
The size of my deck.
Sorry,
what are we talking about?
The deck.
Oh my God.
Look how far it goes in.
Yeah,
Jesus Christ.
It's huge.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Oh my goodness.
Look at that.
Oh my God.
That's freaking me out.
How does that not just like the
mechanical leverage,
seems like it would just snap your
femur.
Well,
a leg kick.
Do you think you'd be taken down?
Okay.
I.
I would,
I would.
Please don't.
Please don't give so many right at the
bottom of that spike.
That's a wrap on.
Yeah.
I feel like right where that spike
connects to the meet.
I feel like someone who's got a real
good leg kick,
which is going right through that.
That's why,
but I think the bone density a,
what happens with the bone density is
that's why the appealing process is so
slow because the bone is actually
healing around that thing.
Right.
That's maybe in theory more dense than
the actual spike.
Whoa,
but you're right.
Just the physics of hitting kicking that
you would think would.
That's your.
That's your weak spot.
What about like falling and stuff?
Do they advise you?
The one thing they don't have you do is
if you were to bend my leg back when I
need back that way,
like a lunge back onto this kind of
thing,
it will pop out forward of Jesus Christ.
Now I'm even with no wait a no.
It would have to be some kind of weight
that will push forward.
It used to be the way if I put my knees
up on my chest to do like butterfly,
the way that they designed the hit
before it would actually pop out that
way,
but now they've fixed it where it's like
it has to be this other extreme angle to
get it to pop out,
but it can pop out.
Has it popped out on you yet?
No,
it has not.
Do you do any weight lifting to
strengthen everything around?
It was a lot of,
a lot of walking,
you know,
uh,
some,
some weight training.
I really liked the kettle bells when
that stuff.
Um,
I think just that,
just that wrestling,
you know,
working with somebody,
not actually doing the take downs for
warmup.
I'd do take downs,
but you know,
just that act of,
of lateral front back and then having
somebody pull you with those different
ways and the low stance.
Yeah,
low stance.
I liked that low center of gravity drop
then that's good for the legs for sure.
So kettlebells that the battle ropes,
those do body weight squats.
I do not.
I'm a big fan of body weight squats.
You're Hindu squats,
they call them.
Which type of squat that you do.
Will you do like a lot of reps?
I'll do 200 reps and what it's hard to
do.
It's not.
It seems like it's easy because you do
the first 10,
you're like,
I can do 200 and then you get to 20.
You're like,
Ooh.
And then you get to 50,
so there's no way you just,
you doing your thing.
Just me.
And you go,
you go down,
you touched your,
you drop your hands back,
you touch your hands to the ground.
And then as you go up you bring your
hands up for like,
I'll fuck that.
It looks like this.
Hang on,
hang on.
I called Hindu squatting and gotta get
counter ever.
What you stand like this and you,
you stand with your back straight up and
your hands are like behind your button.
You go down like this one,
two,
three.
And as I'm going down,
my heels go up.
So at the bottom,
like at the bottom,
I'm actually on the ball of my feet and
my hands go behind my heels,
right?
And then as I come up,
I touched the ground and I go up to this
position and I breathe out as I do this,
I'm going to 100,
200 of these bitches.
I just done like five and I'm ready to
take a nap.
He'll just keep going.
Let's have a donut.
Can we just have donuts?
No,
man.
I'm A.
I think a lot of people don't do enough
shit with their legs.
Is that what you do?
Is that the more shit you do with your
legs where it's running or squatting or
dead lifting?
It just your whole body feels better and
people neglect that shit.
Yeah,
I do more leg,
stuff like that.
Then I do arm stuff.
I think my next step is I talked about
before is like,
you know,
I had broken my wrists.
I think the last time I was in here,
I like that actually was a broken wrist
out.
A sprained wrist.
Oh yeah.
So I actually broke both my wrists that
year.
Um,
and I had shoulder issues.
A rotator shit issue.
So one thing too that I did those,
uh,
stem cells and not the,
a prp,
not the PRP.
The other one.
That one?
Yeah,
I think so.
That one.
Where'd you do it?
Uh,
in Arizona they were,
they were doing show.
Really?
They're not cheap.
No,
no.
It's not cheap.
They take your own blood and do it.
No,
it's not.
Regina King must be something different.
Okay.
So it's like,
you know,
something like that.
And then I started researching going,
Oh,
you know,
we just discovered Hep c a couple of
years ago,
maybe I shouldn't be putting some kind
of weird foreign shit.
And they just discovered Hep c a couple
of years.
Just hepatitis than general.
Like it's,
you know,
it's like on the rise.
Well,
20 years ago people didn't know what the
hell that was,
you know,
30 years ago they just thought people
were skanks.
There are no gangs have actually like
terrible diseases,
male and female.
I'm just thinking and just in general,
like uh,
you know,
things that we hear here,
take some Prozac and then no,
don't take any PROZAC.
Just changing their minds about every
thing that they put in.
You are polite of you,
that's for sure.
That's for sure.
True.
So,
you know,
I,
I stopped,
I want to do more what you were doing
with the actually spinning out your own
stem cells.
There's a couple of different procedures
that they're doing now.
One of them that's really important as
they're shooting stem cells directly
into disc tissue,
so people that have bulging discs in my,
they're able to heal the discs and
actually create more disc tissue and
this is all super cutting edge stuff
with the stem cell technologies,
some of the most intriguing and
fascinating things going on right now in
modern medicine.
So they're,
they're able to do amazing work.
I mean,
it's just,
they think that within a few years
they're going to be able to fix things.
Here's one thing they're doing.
This is really important for people.
I better not forget this,
when the used to blow out things like
acl,
they used to have to replace it.
They used to either replace it with a
cadaver ligament or they would replace
it with,
um,
your Pete Patella tendon.
That would cut a piece of that like I
had that done.
Or they would take your hamstring.
Sometimes they take a chunk of your
hamstring and they screw it in place.
Now they have a new method real knew
where they can actually.
They've figured out a way to
repair the actual acl itself.
They figured out how to tie it back
together again in heals.
It heals way quicker.
You're walking almost instantly like
after the surgery and you're back to
action in three months.
It's a totally different ballgame.
They had this guy who competed in the
Olympics five months after getting the
surgery on his Achilles.
He blew out his Achilles and he used to
be like,
instantaneously your leg was useless and
it was useless for like a year.
Now this guy is five months later is
competing in the Olympics and they're
shooting stem cells in there to help the
healing.
It's fucking crazy what's going on right
now that's not.
We're living in an awesome time.
Yeah.
I mean for a guy like Hickson who has
all those back problems,
man,
this is.
Let's get them on that.
I know,
right?
Yeah.
I think Hixon is all like holistic
though.
You know,
he wants to just do yoga and ride off
into the sunset on somebody like a pale
horse or some shit.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Like meditate on something where they
light it on fire and that's how he's
going to go out.
You know what?
I mean,
I don't know how much he's into getting
a bunch of stuff shot into him.
I mean,
I think I admire that a lot of ways.
he's a fascinating character and he's
the guy,
in my opinion,
that opened up a lot of people's eyes to
yoga from that choke documentary.
Yeah.
People saw that and they were like,
oh wait a minute.
Yeah.
The baddest motherfucker on earth does
yoga.
Does Yoga.
Yeah.
And when you see what he can do with his
body,
like,
oh,
well of course.
How are you going to hold onto that guy?
Look,
look at how we can move.
Yeah.
Could you stand up on a balance beam and
do a full split holding his foot over
his head and he's 40.
You know,
at the time he was.
Now he's in his fifties.
He's amazing.
Quite a quite a fascinating guy,
but not interested in getting shot up
with stem cells.
I am.
Sign me up.
I don't know.
I don't have problems with my acl.
I just want to do it.
Let's just do it.
Just do it.
Shoot it in there,
shoot it everywhere.
That what happens,
some people go down to Mexico and they
get it shot into their veins.
That Dan Bilzerian Guy,
you know,
that guy is the uh,
Internet.
Uh,
he's,
he's hilarious.
I've had him on the podcast before.
He's a poker player and he has been so
famous from being this like Internet guy
with a ton of money that flies around in
jets and has all these hot chicks with
him.
He's always like shooting guns,
driving Dune buggies and shit.
He goes down to Mexico all the time.
It gets a shot in his veins
intravenously.
And I'm like,
well,
what does it do for you?
He's like,
I don't know.
I feel fucking great.
Great.
No good.
Is it bad?
No one exactly knows.
Right?
But they take stem cells and they just
got electrolytes.
They launching and in you intervene boss
route and said he did it.
He felt like he had power coming.
He
lies.
It was like I had light coming out of my
hands like that.
Like the first time you did meth.
Okay.
No,
I think it's better than that.
Okay.
Do better than that.
Meth and ecstasy together.
All right.
It's like a little like your energetic,
but you're also loving.
I think there's something to,
uh,
what we're doing right now where I think
within the next 20 or 30 years we're
going to have a real,
real problem with people not dying.
GRANDPA.
Now with the current administration,
I think it could be all right with that.
Do you think that motherfucker,
he so ego maniacal.
Don't you think you'd be shooting stem
cells into himself and tries to keep
himself alive forever?
Yeah,
but he's going to send anybody else off
to go fight for the materials that go
into those shots.
Madge,
you trump found out about it before
anybody started reverse aging.
Like Benjamin buttons would be amazing.
Just all of a sudden trump is like
younger again,
kind of freaking everybody out.
We know he's 90,
but he looks great.
Yeah.
As long as he goes all the way down and
we can put them over your knee and like
a baby.
Give him a time out.
What do you think he's going to happen
with this dude?
Um,
I think it's a smokescreen.
I think there's so many other things
going on that,
uh,
that we're not paying attention to,
but it is a testament to,
um,
just,
just the level of frustrations I think
that people have had just with
government in general and the Internet
and social media has been able to
polarize us all enough to where we don't
talk to each other to really sort of
sought out some of the,
you know,
the actual issues that are going on.
So they had this,
this spectacle I'm going on right now
that,
uh,
it's,
it's amazing.
It is a spectacle,
but I always wonder whether or not it's
an orchestra orchestrated spectacle or
whether we just try to find patterns
when patterns don't even exist.
And what it really is,
is just,
this is just a goofy dude who loves
attention and we have a fucking
popularity contest to see who runs the
country and you get,
like I say,
go back,
just back it up
to see where people really frustrated
with the Obama administration.
Were they frustrated with the Bush
administration?
Whether you know,
whether is it,
is it connected or are they just looking
for something different?
Because if you look historically at at
places that have had some success as a
country and then they have some
problems,
we started seeing some issues and
they're just whatever the incumbent a
person is a,
the party,
the group I'm all they want is something
else.
Something different.
We want to get rid of that,
but something different in and
historically when that happens,
shit just go sideways that just pick it.
They just wanted anything else and they
got exactly what they got.
Something worse.
Worse.
Yeah.
That's the problem is worrying about it
the same way you worried about
technology.
Like one guy can one day create one
thing and it fucking ruins everything
and you almost feel like that with like
a president.
Like we can ask for something different
and then one day we get it and it
fucking ruins everything like that.
What I worry about is
a lot of what he's doing with this
battle against the intelligence
agencies,
all the shitty talks about them.
It's like if they start hiding stuff
from him because they're worried that
he's going to tell stuff to Russian guys
and you know,
and talk about certain things like he
revealed top secret information about
isis wants to use laptops is bombed.
He told the Russians that if they can't
trust him and if they developed this
thing where it's them versus him.
Did you gotta you got a real serious
problem on your hands that.
Because that's gonna that attitude's
going to carry onto the next
administration,
whether it's pants or some Democrat or
whoever the fuck comes in after him.
Right?
Fuck man.
It's all scary.
It's just people didn't know what they
were voting for.
They didn't understand.
They thought they thought it was going
to be.
We're going to drain the swamp.
Like this motherfucker just,
he just backed up the biggest sewer
truck ever to the swamp and he's shit in
there like crazy.
Yeah.
Well I,
you know,
I agree,
but I think the,
the,
the all again y'all.
All we can do I think is to step back
and fight.
Fight the battle.
So here,
you know,
if you can think of the battlefield as
being your,
your old school,
uh,
you know,
there's the goals over there.
Capture the flag kind of battlefield.
Your first battle is his ignorance.
Your first enemy is ignorance.
Trying to figure out how to get past the
misinformation that you know,
all that stuff.
Just to get past ignorance.
It,
educate yourself.
First of all,
the earth is not flat.
You don't think there it's flat.
I think we need to see a rock from the
sky slam into the earth.
I think that's what we need.
We need like a small European city wiped
out just so we go,
oh,
okay,
well this is,
this is crazy.
What are we concentrating on?
Bullshit.
Goddamn shooting gallery art.
Life is just so short.
We don't understand the real spans of
time.
Right?
We don't understand that periodically.
This fucking whole thing's going to get
rattled.
Yes.
Extremely.
No doubt about it.
It's coming.
Yeah.
So I think that's,
you know,
it's idle,
idle hands are the devil's playground.
You've heard that cliche and I think
that really is,
you know.
Um,
so my prepper,
that prepper side of me is that person
who,
you know,
what if we don't have,
what if you don't have electricity for a
week because whatever,
for whatever reason,
why,
yeah,
just,
you know,
just be having an understanding of what
that is.
Um,
so that one is just a starter,
a precursor or just a,
a,
a dry run of what,
what happens when that rock does fall
from the sky because it happens all the
time because,
you know,
historically historically of happens a
lot.
Uh,
and I do believe that that is the,
that would be the,
that would be the reset button.
I prefer not to have that be the reset,
but I'd prefer to,
their consciousness caught up with
itself and we just kind of start to each
other.
I would like that too,
but I think we need something.
Maybe a little shake them up.
Maybe it doesn't even have to hit a
city.
Like how about hit the ocean and we
catch it on video.
Just bone mile high waves wipes out all
of Carbon Beach Malibu.
Come on,
son,
all those billion dollar,
they call that billionaire beach.
He's fucking assholes.
They would only work.
It would only work if it,
if it was a global event,
right?
Because if it's isolated,
because we've had tsunamis so large,
we don't care.
Large cities,
nobody.
Nobody does anything about it.
It would have to be.
We had Katrina that,
but that's down there with those people.
It needs to be something that's
nationwide that that hits all of us at
the same time where we stopped with this
bullshit,
stop with this polarized bullshit and
start talking to each other.
This is what happens.
Connor connects with the lefthand and
floyd methods when made,
whether it's Chin Floyd goes down and at
the count of eight when he's about to
get up,
the whole arena gets hit with a media
boom.
Last Vegas is wiped off the face of the
planet.
Everybody's dead,
but we saw the feed up until the
asteroid impact it.
Just one big bright spark of light,
but then everybody starts tuning into
CNN.
There's a huge crater where vegas used
to be,
and the asteroid though has an emp that
hits every single fee that goes to every
single camera and TV and it wipes out
every electronic device that's been
watching the whole thing now.
Now you're getting too crazy.
Wait a minute.
That's.
Can we just need to wipe out?
They helped me out here.
We don't even need to wipe out Vegas.
I Love Vegas.
Don't get me wrong.
Yeah.
I just feel like we need something where
people are,
they have to.
It has to affect them.
It has to affect them on some level.
That actually the
kickstarts their compassion gene.
You're,
you know,
you want to have a balance between your
survival gene and your compassion Jane,
because you know,
you got to figure back a long time ago.
The thing that,
that,
that helped us be here today is we
weren't,
we weren't stronger.
We weren't faster,
uh,
than we are.
We weren't larger than the things that
we're eating us.
We had to be smarter.
We have to be clever.
We had to come up with ways to create
something from nothing to be able to
defend ourselves against predators or
refinanced,
so that creative,
that creative juice was there and we
were trying to,
we were establishing food,
shelter,
and clothing as well as keeping
protected from predators.
And it was that creative side of us,
that artistic side of us that actually
was too.
That's what you have to think that,
that creative side of us to keep us
ahead of these creatures,
the elements,
um,
all these things.
And as time has gone on,
when you no longer are threatened by
these things,
there's no,
there's plenty of clothes everywhere.
Pretty much plenty of food everywhere
where we live and a lot of idle hands,
idle hands.
So we've lost
touch with that imminent threats.
So we have,
we started to turn on each other,
all those girls with fake assets.
People get mad.
I'm mad that he has a lady.
What's her name?
It gives you.
I was eating all these people angry at
her because there were assets,
fat,
angry,
just angry at a fake ass.
Well,
they don't even have a mic rib here at
the Mcdonald's Arizona.
Keep them big.
Rib Eye had 12 seasons.
That's.
No,
no,
no disrespect to the people that they
get caught up in that broken nail
syndrome,
but like that is what it is.
That's your,
your tragedies are not tragedies.
So we need some kind of life threatening
something that's really global and it's.
It crosses religious,
economic,
social,
racial.
It has to cross all those lines to where
people are like,
what the fuck?
Yeah.
It has to expose micro aggressions for
the preposterous notion that there
really are.
Like if you get hit in the head with a
media,
someone gets mad at a microaggression.
There's,
there are two very different things.
You see that meter almost hit him.
Okay.
Let me see.
The meter almost hit her.
Yeah.
CIS gendered piece of Shit.
Living with all those cowboys and
Arizona.
Yeah,
whatever,
Bro.
I'm a big fan,
Arizona.
Some of my favorite people.
If there is any one of my bathrooms,
feel free.
Thank you.
That's sweet.
Do you.
Do you have a restaurant there too?
Yeah,
we just opened a North Korea,
so fuck.
Do you have time for all this?
I don't do it myself.
Okay.
That's the planet.
I get it all going and then I hand that
off to Austin people.
That's a good move.
So Jesse and creator curator of also
we're running that thing.
Um,
uh,
Brianna a,
it's a Alstroemeria.
So what is Austria a basically a wine
bar with,
with food.
So it's a,
you know,
a gathering place where you're like,
that place I'm going to in studio city?
Yes.
What's that place called?
Augustine wine bar.
God Damn,
that was good.
Yeah,
the food was amazing to.
Yes.
Awesome.
Matthew Caner,
wonderful place.
It brought up some like 19,
21.
Oh yeah,
we did some.
We did you.
He raped me that night.
Not Financially.
Yes.
Financially and it wasn't my idea.
I didn't know how to spend that much
money.
I don't know what kind of wine that was,
but it was fascinating wine that was
like,
Ooh,
this is wine.
Yeah,
I kinda got it for a brief moment.
Yeah.
And then I wandered off on some tangent.
I think I actually said I think as like,
hey,
set up a fight with me and bordain the
you wanted to fight somebody.
I don't think it was important to.
One day might kill you,
dude.
I was pretty drunk.
He's crazy and he's got the crazy gene
for sure.
He's got that.
I used to be a former heroin addict and
almost died.
Jean,
you know,
it'll only gets activated and people
that have been to the brink of death.
Yeah,
I've met a bunch of people like that
though.
I think it's a real thing.
I think there's something that happens.
There's some scary people like Matt
Brown,
the guy who fights in the UFC,
same kind of gene.
He's got that.
I used to die.
I died,
but I came back.
Jean,
I met him.
He's really Nice Guy,
a nice guy,
but there's that edge of like,
I think maybe they've been to the dark
lands when people have been to the dark
men's,
they come back different.
So like Stephen King's pet cemetery,
you know,
you barely the cat comes back to life
and it's like,
okay,
bring the cat back.
So fuck.
Don't fuck with that cat.
That is something that happens to people
when they've been to the darklands yeah.
Yeah.
So the listeria,
it's Arizona grows its own wheat,
so all of our breads are from Arizona.
Wait.
Oh,
okay.
Let me ask you.
This.
Is,
that is.
Can you please not do that?
We're talking Jimmy,
Jimmy,
Phil.
This is a new,
a Jimi Hendrix poster that we have.
If you notice in the background folks,
because the old one was not really his
mugshot.
The new one is actually his mugshot.
So we had it swapped out.
This is the real Jimi Hendrix mugshot
thing.
Broke fix that.
Don't worry about it folks.
We're going to be fun.
Is it true about wheat that there are
strains that are wild or a rather
unmodified that are much more easy for
the body to digest?
So Hayden Mills is one of the many,
uh,
down in Phoenix that are actually
milling the local waste.
So they're looking,
they're basically cultivating a around
southern Arizona heirloom weight and
that's the idea they're going back to.
Uh,
the problem with that,
of course it's always got to get the
give and take is that those heirloom
pure heirloom wheats to have far less
complex glutens and um,
uh,
and there's far they don't produce as
much wheat,
so just your production on an acre of
land is,
is significantly lower for this stuff,
but it's tastier,
it has more nutrients.
And then from there,
the next step of course is people
understanding a time.
So you're,
you're taking that wheat,
you're mailing it,
and then when you go to make your bread,
any kind of fermentation in that,
that you're getting your,
your,
uh,
inoculating that to make your bread,
that sitting,
letting this dose it overnight,
you're letting it rise for a longer
period of time because that whole
process is breaking down those glutens.
Oh,
okay.
So my sourdough bread is free.
So because most commercial commercial
bread,
the fermentation,
you know,
the rising that doe is,
is,
is almost instantaneous and it goes
right into the oven.
And then people are not chewing their
food,
they're just cramming it in.
And it's probably coming from places
that are doing a lot of pesticides and
all the extra stuff that's going on
those,
those crops.
So the heirloom wheat movement ends up
tying hand in hand in hand with,
with understanding the slow food
movement.
Take,
take your minute,
chew your food,
understanding where your food comes
from,
try to get it organic and local.
Um,
and it goes,
that goes all the way back to the wheat.
So yes.
So there.
So to answer your question,
yeah,
the,
what happened is they over world war one
to try and make sure that people are
going to be fed during those wars.
They were manipulating the wheat so that
it was much higher production weight.
But now the flavor's gone.
The nutrition's not there,
uh,
it being resistant to all these things
that all the glutens are very complex.
And then so when you were actually big
and making the bread out of these things
are making positives out of them,
it's just there's all this extra crap,
you know,
if you created a Frankenstein's monster
with this wheat.
So your body of course is reacting to
all those things that have nothing to do
with actually having bread or having
wheat.
It's a very controversial.
A lot of people try to claim that there
is no difference between the we'd have
today and the weight of the past and
they also try to claim that the only
people that have issues with gluten are
people that have gluten sensitivity,
celiac disease,
things along those lines.
And My,
my gripe with that is that I always feel
that the people that say that they don't
have a good sense of their body,
I don't think they're real athletes
because I think when you talk to a real.
I'm not saying that you can't perform
like a real world class athlete by
eating pasta.
You definitely can.
What I think is we want to talk about
total optimization.
If you want to talk about your body like
running as smoothly as possible.
For me at least,
I notice a difference between eating a
lot of bread and gluten,
which I used to do a lot and not doing
it.
When I don't do it,
I just feel better.
I have more energy,
I feel like my body's struggles less
digestive food and I don't have the big
crash after the food is over.
It doesn't mean that I can't perform on
it.
Like I don't have a gluten sensitivity
issue.
Like I can eat it.
It's not,
that's not the problem.
If someone said,
oh,
you're fine,
you eat it.
It's no big deal.
It's not that.
I don't think it's the optimal thing to
do.
I just think that it's delicious.
I don't think it's killing me,
but I don't think if you want to give
your body the very best fuel pasta,
like regular pasta isn't that fuel,
but I wonder if you can get some of that
heirloom pasta if you would notice a
difference.
I wonder if you would feel the
difference in trying the two.
Okay.
So similar conversation parallel.
You're in,
you're in Italy,
you're having bottles of wine,
you're having gender.
Uh,
it tastes great.
You had a good time,
you woke up the next day,
he didn't have a hangover.
All those things over here.
I have wine and I get hangovers and I
get sick and I do those things and it's
like,
so it must be that the Italian wine is
better or has less sulfites or something
like that was like,
well,
most likely what it was is over here.
You're a fat pig and you sat in your
house and you drank a bottle of wine
with your buddies without taking a walk
in a foreign country because you're
walking to your restaurant there,
you're having food and you're eating
over the course of three hours with your
friends and you're eating food with your
wine.
You're eating less of it.
Most likely it has a lower alcohol
content because it's meant to go with
food rather than being this mountain dew
with alcohol in it that you get out of
California,
you know,
it's.
It's all for one ones that I did not.
I did not all for California,
Arizona thing we're going on.
Right,
and maybe you're fucked.
You're fucked.
Okay.
Good to know.
So I think there's an experiential thing
that's happening with those
conversations and it's the same thing
with the pasta.
Pasta makes me feel sluggish.
You eight,
17 pounds of it,
right?
Don't eat 17 pounds of it,
but yes,
going back to having just the initiation
of like understanding the conversation
of heirloom wheat and understanding that
there's a difference.
Arguing that there is a difference.
Even if there isn't now you're looking
at it.
Maybe you're having less of it.
Maybe you're,
maybe you're portioning out better and
you're paying attention to your diet
more.
Hey,
that's a step in the right direction.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I read something about the French.
The French are always eating bread,
but they do have that older wheat bread
and they eat a lot of fats with their
bread,
like it's constantly with butter and oil
and they cook with a lot of butter and
oil in that,
those carbs in that oil together.
Apparently it's just a better fit for
your digestive system.
I could,
I could see that.
I kind of did that.
I didn't stick to it.
Letter of the law,
but I did a little bit of Kenogenic Diet
for a minute where I cut out sugars,
carbs,
all those things.
Just feel,
uh,
I felt a lot better a right away now.
Now I go back and I'll have some pasta
once or twice a month in small portions.
I'll have some bread,
but I don't eat a lot of it.
I enjoy it better now more.
It's not you.
It's a treat.
It's enough,
you know that at that point like,
you know,
proteins and vegetables are the staple
and I have,
I have treats now.
Yeah.
I feel the exact same way.
I feel like I have my nutrition which is
like I try to eat really healthy food 80
percent of the time and then 20 percent
of the time I like to go to a restaurant
and get linguine with clams.
You know,
it's just,
it's just an experience.
It's a delicious experience.
I know it's not the best thing for me,
but it's a treat.
Yeah.
You're,
you,
you know,
this is,
you get one life,
so let's enjoy it.
Also,
especially like what you're doing,
like having,
when you have a restaurant,
I mean you're selling an experience,
right?
Like it's just delicious wines and
delicious foods.
And the two of them together with
conversation and saw that,
you know,
and you're like,
oh,
try this,
you know,
like when people are doing that and it's
like this whole sensory experience is
all combined together.
It's not just about nutrition,
it's about the art of creating this
sensory experience.
One could argue that your,
your wellbeing,
uh,
is,
is you're,
you're actually increasing your life
experience here and your and your
quality of life by having this
experience with these people,
these wines that you
actually feel better tomorrow and next
week because of that interaction because
of that short,
even though like that's straight butter
and that's straight,
you know?
Yeah.
And wine.
But no,
I think you're 100 percent right.
I think that's a,
that's sort of an overlooked aspect of
health is that positive experiences.
And,
and just also like when you go to a
really good restaurant and especially if
you get to meet the cook,
you know,
like you meet someone to cook something
for you,
you can say thank you and you have this
like cool feedback with the person who
made your food.
It's like there's something going on
there,
it's like this exchange,
it's,
and it's,
it's like a sand castle and the way it's
beautiful,
it's amazing how the fucking the skill
involved in creating it,
but then it's going to go away.
You know,
it's gone.
It's,
it was a temporary experience and in
this world of,
you know,
the NSA stockpiling text messages and
Dick Pics and some fucking warehouse in
Utah,
you know,
we lost it is,
it is.
They've got to address,
I don't know the address.
If I known that I wouldn't give it out,
they'd come get me,
come get you and tell you now we're
doubling down on your Dick Pics and
they've got a fucking warehouse.
Gigantic like costco filled with
slightly bigger warehouse but a bigger
fucking Irish.
Yeah.
I,
I think um,
I mean in the concerts too,
right?
Like live concerts or kind of that way
too,
right?
Like that's a temporary experience.
I mean there's one thing to listen to a
song that you have on your phone.
You can listen to it over and over
again,
but when you're going to see a live
concert,
you're experiencing the guy like onstage
sing that song.
You're experiencing the sound coming out
of the guitar.
Right?
When the guys touching the cords,
that's why this.
That's why this stuff annoys me.
The phones at the shows because I'm a
firm believer in oral tradition.
I feel like I'm a firm believer.
I just.
I embrace the storytelling.
I embraced that whole tradition of oral
tradition and being able to describe to
your friends that sitting around that,
you know,
fire after a good,
long day of hunting will you tell the
story of the hunt and do all those
things and those and those family
stories and other,
you know,
your grandfather and your great
grandfather's father's stories are told
in that setting and you have to remember
that there's.
You're not reading it down.
It's,
it's a.
it's a tradition of of understanding the
details of being able to explain and
expand on the details from what your
recollection of what you saw,
but if you have no skills of absorbing
what you saw,
if you rely on this thing to capture
their stories for you,
first of all,
nothing you're going to get at a show is
going to be represented that represent
what you just saw or what you were there
for.
I guess as a postcard,
I suppose it works,
but like it's not state presidents day
with these people to be there for this
thing that's far more important and you
know also as critical.
Maybe the behind you would like
to be that person who's willing to sell
that and now your shit's in their way.
Some people hold up fucking ipads.
There's 12 inch ipad,
some dude at the laugh factory the other
day I had a fucking ipad.
The people behind you have to like,
yeah,
you're holding up an IPAD.
It's crazy to see everybody's got their
phone out.
So the first,
that first barrier we talked about the
ignorance.
Just getting past understanding how to
just get past not just what you think
you know,
all those things,
erasing,
erasing everything.
Think you now get past the ignorant,
your own ignorance.
First of all,
right?
Uh,
but just then that situational awareness
is kind of goes in hand in hand with
that.
Who are you?
Not only in your world,
but who are you in other people's world?
When I'm driving my,
my primary mission is to get out of your
way.
I want to get out of the way.
I want to get where I'm going.
I'm going to get out of the way.
I don't want to have you get out of my
way because I'm going to a place.
I'm paying attention to where you are as
I'm driving.
Because if I think like that,
if I think I'm in your way,
this is all gonna work out better.
We're all gonna.
Get along.
If you think like that on the road,
like I am in your way,
let me figure out how I can make sure
that I'm,
I'm getting where I'm going.
I'm not gonna put myself out.
I'm not sure it's going to pull over the
side of the road while you all drive by.
Um,
I'm going to get out of the way so that
I make it convenient for you to get
where you're going as well.
We're all going someplace,
right?
We're in a car right away.
Let's not.
Let's not fight here.
Yeah,
let's not film ourselves driving either.
Right?
I saw someone facetiming while they're
driving and holding up the phone,
talking to someone I'm passing by.
I saw a dude doing candy crush awhile
back playing candy crush on his phone.
It's like,
whoa.
People film,
fireworks.
Does anybody ever watch it?
That makes no sense to me.
Yeah.
You send it,
dude.
You wouldn't believe the fireworks.
I'm going to send it to you to please
send it.
I can't wait to see it.
Wait to see the video of fireworks.
Can I put it on instagram?
Do you mind if I read Graham your
fireworks and brought it up?
I'd rather not.
I'd really like all the hits.
This is a big,
big,
awful video.
The thought of Focus.
You can't even tell what the fuck it is.
You see some lights flashing off,
but when you go to a fireworks display,
you see 50 fucking people holding up
their God damn phones.
Yeah.
What are you doing?
What have you got?
Damn life.
Live your fucking life,
right?
Speaking to live your life.
When you.
Since you signed up,
man,
I'm always round up.
I got a problem
down randomly.
Connor
fucking settle down.
Settle down on a.
put you down when you have so many
different projects.
How do you choose like what to it?
Like when you take on something like a
restaurant or you know,
opening this Jujitsu school or any of
the number of numerous projects that you
do.
You already are so fucking busy.
You have a family.
You already have these businesses and
bands.
How do you decide like what
to do?
You just go on your instinct like what
Uh,
well,
you know,
everything has its own individual needs.
So and the,
and what kinds of bands are touring or
writing?
There are absolute needs and processes.
A lead times,
right?
If you're going to put out a book,
you have to,
you have to understand that there's a
head low.
He said,
as he wrote a book to fuck,
he plugged the device.
We feel lazy.
He's one of the few people I know that
makes me.
I've wrote,
I read it to Sarah.
I,
you know,
I was,
I was involved,
uh,
you can credit,
goes to our attention with maynard James
Keenan.
Guess a perfect union of contrary
things,
bone with my American.
Um,
yeah.
So it's,
it's a,
it's understanding,
organizing your time.
Delegating is huge.
Understanding of what it's going to
take,
what kind of effort it's going to take
for those things when it comes to
winemaking,
unblocked down for that period of time
when it comes to writing,
for example,
with a tool or with perfect circle
there,
Christopher understanding,
uh,
you know,
timing.
And we can get into that in a minute.
Wait,
wait,
no.
Okay.
Um,
uh,
yeah,
so it's,
it really does come down to
understanding.
I'm really good at planning,
uh,
planning ahead and looking at things.
So if I think,
uh,
if,
if somebody comes along and says,
hey,
we're going to do a thinking about doing
a film,
you want to be in the film,
I go,
when is it because I already have my
year.
You should see my schedule.
It's,
it's a year and a half out.
I'm brilliant.
Just locked in.
Yeah,
because there's,
you know,
there's things that I know that if a,
for example,
if you're going to put out a vinyl as a
band,
generally speaking,
unless you're somebody who can make some
calls and cut some corners,
if you're going to deliver a master to
actually cut vinyl and now as you want
your vulnerable to come out Monday that
you record comes out.
You don't want it to be a delayed thing
and have it all be scattered.
Um,
it takes three months that,
that's your,
that's your lead time for production.
No less than no less than three months
is what you have.
Like an,
you have to make an order,
like,
say like x amount of thousands that you
have.
So you have to plan ahead.
So if you,
if the,
if you finally get all your shit
together and you've got your,
you got your masters,
you're going to do a thing.
I'm a,
then you have to go,
okay,
well then wants,
that's wants,
that's their,
uh,
the release date can't be any sooner
than this date.
What that date is,
January first.
That's not good.
Nobody really uses a record on January
first just because it's a bad time to
release a record.
Just came out of Christmas.
It's like,
it's like business wise,
they just don't,
you just don't do that.
I'm having a rock concert on a New
Year's Eve.
That's a different thing.
People that are out partying,
they're going to do their thing.
So you're going to release a record in
the spring,
you're going to release record in the
fall.
That's when you release it.
Generally speaking,
people will release all summer as well,
but the optimum times,
our optimum times.
So just knowing that,
okay,
well if it takes that long to produce
the record and get set up,
press and do interviews,
you know,
as for lead times in a magazine or
online where they've,
you know,
interviews are schedule that we had this
planned amongst go a couple of months
ago because I couldn't just,
you couldn't,
you would just call me last week and go,
hey,
you're gonna come in now.
We don't know what our schedules are.
So you're thinking ahead.
Right?
So same thing with the music,
you're always,
you're always kind of looking ahead to
go,
well,
in order to deliver that master,
that means we had to be mastering that
piece by here and we had to be mixing
and mixing and then looking at the mixes
again and fixing anything.
It's meant to retract something and it
kind of scrambling last minute before
mixing.
That's going to take this amount of
time.
Well,
in order to mix,
we have to track,
right?
So you have to have everything written
before you can actually track it to mix
it,
generally speaking.
So that means all the songs have to be
written by this day,
if we're going to record all of them and
mix all of them and master all of them
and release them all on the same day.
Right.
Well,
so you have to think all the way back to
that day.
Like,
where are we today?
Are Those songs finished today?
Cool.
Then we can start recording,
um,
tomorrow or next week?
No.
How do you know when a song is finished?
Like do you,
if you give yourself a deadline,
let's say if you say,
um,
you know,
we have six months to complete this
album or whatever it would be.
And you have a song that like,
man,
it's just something about the songs.
This doesn't feel right.
It's not done.
Just something feels off like how do
you,
how do you finish something by a
deadline?
Um,
sometimes you don't,
so you just take it out of the album and
put it aside for later or how do you,
how do you do that?
Yeah,
of course.
That varies with everybody.
Um,
if it's not ready,
it's not ready.
So you keep delaying and try to get it
right,
I guess.
Are you second guessing or you start
realizing,
uh,
these are just some things we should
just finish them.
Hm.
Well,
you know,
remember that feeling when you were a
kid when you get an album and some of
the songs were just fucking amazing and
then you would hear like one or two or
what the fuck is this piece of shit?
How did this get on a rolling stones
album?
And that was likely because they had a
deadline and their record company made
them,
they don't,
you know,
they were locked into a contract that
said that they had to deliver by a
certain time.
Right.
But if you're not locked into that kind
of a contract,
then you can kind of take forever,
which is an equally awful thing
to you.
Free of contracts.
Now,
are you your own man?
It comes to mutual.
Has One more time record
under a contract.
I'm perfect.
Circle.
Just signed up for a,
a one,
a one album deal through a,
through a company.
Um,
to do you know,
it's one off album by post suffers an
independent project.
We've been independent from the
beginning.
So do you prefer that or is there
benefits to both?
I think there's benefits to all those
things.
Depends on,
it depends on how many,
how much,
how many trust issues you have.
I guess like if you're going to work
with a large company,
if you can trust them to handle and
carry some of the water on some of these
things without getting lost or spilled
or you know,
dumped.
Um,
yeah.
You can work with a company like that.
It depends on your goals I suppose.
Is it like more of a benefit now that
you are.
I mean especially,
I don't know.
I don't know if now you're dealing with
the resurgence of vinyl.
It's been pretty steady over the last
few years,
right?
It's kind of like a,
like a mason jar type thing.
People in the old funky stuff,
you know?
Yeah.
Well I think there's still that
nostalgic feel of touching the vinyl and
then being able to have,
have that thing and listened to it.
Then there is a difference,
but I feel like going back to what you
had mentioned earlier about people
realizing,
oh wait,
I think we need to start looking and
talking to each other again and
reconnecting and I feel like vinyl is
another tip of that iceberg of that
connection of like,
it's not long,
it's that this is so temporary and so
yeah,
a one digital.
Yeah.
So ditch,
so one emp away from all that stuff
being gone.
Your entire,
all those experiences you wasted.
He were,
you were recording the fireworks rather
than actually looking at the fireworks
and then you lost your job or your phone
in the toilet.
It's gone.
Or an emp wipes out all of the servers
that are on your cloud.
And so all of those photos that you
thought were safe somewhere and no
longer.
So you freaked me out here.
Right?
But yeah.
So,
um,
I think vinyl,
there's,
that.
There's a connection,
there's a tactal.
Does it sound better?
I think it does.
Yeah.
I think it does because it depends on,
um,
uh,
are you,
are you creed?
It's never going to sound better.
Dare you.
What about nickelback
shit on all the shit on him with a free
punch.
Hurry up.
Get your shots in.
Judo is a good one.
In sync was always a good one.
Udo.
Wow.
He went deep,
deep backstreet boys.
Remember you.
You should be able to punch,
punch down on them.
It was an easy shot.
I had them in judo album.
Did you know?
Um,
but he takes more punches than
nickelback yeah,
they took a lot of shots.
Yeah.
People just go after them.
And now like they never fight back.
They're like,
what the fuck man?
Because they,
I know on some level they asked for it.
Sorry.
Have they asked for it?
I don't know.
I'm just,
I'm just jumping in on the,
on this rat pack.
They make good stripper music.
Yes,
they do.
You know they make good poll music.
Yeah.
Right.
Girls Spin around.
Pull
your right.
It's nickelback.
Yes.
I think.
Yeah,
I think that is the.
That's the vinyl connection I think is
there's a lot of guys nowadays like tool
for example,
would just.
They'd like analog,
like tracking to tape and to really
translate those things of vinyl is your
perfect medium for that thing.
It's just not very convenient.
There is no record stores.
When I released the first poster for
record in 2007 from the time we started
recording that record until the time we
released it,
there was one number of stores when we
started the recording and there was one
fifth,
the number of stores actually in
existence by the time we actually
released it,
record industry stopped and went away
during that period of time,
so 2007 was when the wave rolled back
like you could see it happen.
It was gone and it was gone and that was
still with best buy's that we're still
selling.
Cds was still part of that one.
Twentieth.
Wow.
Now this is all.
It's all rolled back to where the small
independent stores that weren't greedy,
that really had a relationship with
their customers that enjoyed vinyl,
that had all those things.
Those are the ones that have survived
and thrived.
Like Amoeba.
Yeah.
Those kind of much smaller versions of
those things like Zia records and the
Arizona.
Yeah.
I've seen a few of those on the road and
have gotten into a bunch of them and
they're kind of cool.
It's a totally different thing.
It's almost like you're going to an
antique store,
so I think we is great if you ever go
through stink weeds.
Oh yeah.
There's that in,
uh,
in Arizona.
Oh,
well,
what?
I think tempy Kimberly's going to kill
me.
Tempe.
Um,
because I couldn't remember what it was.
I just do the Tempe Improv all the time.
That's a cool little spot.
Yeah.
Tempe is interesting little town.
That whole area is really awesome.
So,
um,
when you,
when you make a run of those things,
you kind of have to decide like as
they're selling,
when to to make more of them too,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
as a small project like pushed for your,
you know,
we're writing the checks so you don't
want to over,
you don't want to overproduce these
things because then you're kind of
sitting on them and for us at the level
that we're operating,
he always wanted to operate in that
level where it's sustainable.
Right.
That's kind of a beat word.
But yeah,
I,
you know,
I use it all the time because this,
it's the most accurate word to really
look.
Yes.
Sustainable.
If I can keep this thing to keep this
thing alive,
I don't want to keep going back to other
pockets of money to make this thing led
to think should stand on its own.
So you have to be making all these
decisions as if this is an independent
business on its own.
Just ready to survive.
And so yeah,
you have to pay attention to if they
want.
If they want 10,
maybe nine.
Interesting.
Yeah.
They 1:10
make night and keep people wanting more.
Always.
Always told.
Don't live past means right.
Step there in the goldilocks zone.
Yes.
Do you anticipate ever trimming it down
to one band or do you like working with
three different projects?
Well,
I think just the nature of,
of,
of tool in general,
uh,
jump into them,
August one to use just their process in
their writing process is,
is so drawn out.
And I mean,
I'm sure there's a lot of reasons that
go into why the delay has been so long.
Um,
but when you have a project like that,
there's always going to be time for me
to do other things and I will,
I will definitely.
I just liked doing it.
I like doing it more.
I like to release records and write
things a little more quickly than those
guys like to write.
So their process is a very analytical
and I think,
you know,
at some point maybe because so much time
has gone by with a,
from the last album,
there has to be some,
a little bit of fear in there,
you know,
in your gut,
like has or is this record going to be
as good as the last one?
Uh,
you know,
the anticipation now is now the pressure
is huge,
so I'm sure there's some of that goes
into play,
but as far as the way that,
uh,
Danny and Adam and Justin,
right,
it's a very,
very tedious,
a long process and they're always going
back over things and questioning what
they did and stepping back and going
back farther and going forward.
And in a way it's like they're,
they're laying a foundation,
they're putting in the footings for a
house.
So I can't write,
I can't write melodies until the
footings are in place.
I can't write words until the melodies
are in place.
So I can't,
like I can't build walls and then start
decorating this place until the
foundation is in place because if they
keep changing the foundation,
changing the footings,
the melodies change.
And then the story of course isn't
getting written.
So that's where we are.
I mean there's a lot of,
there's a lot of footings that keep
shifting,
lots of awesome footings,
but they keep changing so.
And they keep changing their minds.
So I don't know if it's a good thing or
a bad thing,
it's just their process.
Is this a challenge for you to kind of
manage your own personal expectations
with the work of others and like,
because I know you're so you're very
prolific and you're a guy that just like
you're very disciplined so you always
grinding and then when you manage those
expectations and you're dealing with a
bunch of other artists and you're all
converging together,
converging together on this project
combined cannot make a word up.
I think it just made it up.
Yeah.
So like,
you know,
when you have a lot of very strong
willed,
stubborn,
opinionated people that have had
success,
myself included,
like when you give somebody some
success,
they're pretty,
they're pretty convinced they're right,
you know,
so,
so it's hard to,
it's hard to talk to me or it's hard to
talk to them.
It's hard to talk to people that are in
that position because they've been
successful.
Um,
and so you're,
you think that the reason you got there
is because of whatever position it is
you're taking today,
which is fine.
But our,
you know,
our process has,
has evolved over the years,
uh,
and that,
you know,
that stubborn nature,
he try yet again,
take step back and not take any,
any of these things personally,
you know,
that's our tendency is to like what is
you,
you get that way.
Familiarity breeds contempt kind of
thing.
How much of a problem is expectations of
the fans because the fans like want new
shit,
come on,
where's the fucking new shit?
And that's.
And that's,
you know,
that I'm sure that that was around 15,
20 years ago.
But without social media and without
that direct access of bitching,
you know,
like the star reviews on like the,
on itunes when people are like writing
reviews of shows or music or movies or
whatever.
It's like again,
go to a master,
learned from the master to the point
where you are now,
you have mastership all of that's gone.
It's just like,
it stook it took forever to load.
I don't like the guy with the hair
fucked this one,
one star like
okay,
but like being able to do that.
Yeah,
they love it.
Especially if you work at like Jiffy
Lube when you're sitting there and
you're on your fucking break and you're
smoking a cigarette and you're farting
and you're sitting there like,
fuck the song,
fuck this outfit.
Focus head,
right?
Yeah.
It doesn't really make sense.
So,
and also in my brother's defense,
even billy from perfect circle,
uh,
he's,
he's slow moving as well.
Um,
but he has a lot of,
you know,
now we're starting to work on stuff that
it's taken many years for him to kind of
build up the cash of things that we're,
you know,
we're digging into,
to look at things that have been in
development for the last six,
eight,
10 years.
Well,
you seem to have found this interesting
balance because you're such a,
you,
you have so many different things that
require your focus,
but you're also so,
you,
you're,
you're one of those dudes that has to
get shit done.
I've met a lot of guys like you that
just like,
I'm getting shit done.
You're either my way or you're going to
help me.
Are you gonna?
Get the fuck out of my way.
But I'm getting shit done and so you're
like,
okay,
I can't get shit done over here.
I'm going to get shit done over here.
I'm going to go do this,
I'm going to start a wine company now
making a restaurant.
Oh look,
I have a Jujitsu school.
Look,
I wrote a book and you're just
constantly.
It's fascinating because you're also
pretty at peace,
like you've found like this strange
balance of activity and then also
relative isolation and your small area
took
me awhile to like,
you know,
my,
my desire to move forward with go,
go,
go and get things done.
You know,
I'm always butting heads heads with and
the guys in the band and tool to get
those things done and just,
it's just not their process.
So it took me a while for me to go,
this is not personal,
this is just them.
This is just the way that they have to
do it and I have to respect it.
And I had to take my time and let them
take their time and I just check in.
I just go,
I come and I see what's going on.
Hey Justin,
uh,
some may send me the track,
see where we're at,
is this thing done?
If this thing is done done and I can
start writing words and music on it.
Great.
But I've had instances where I've
started to write stuff and by the time I
actually got it around and back and
we're at last,
she listening and whatever the Ta had
gone in a completely different
direction.
So everything that was written melody
wise or lyric wise was completely
irrelevant.
Now I have to start over.
Is that weird because you guys aren't in
the same location.
Physically I can sit there in that room
a and be with them in that room,
but their process is so tedious and so
like rain man.
Then I just can't.
I just started fucking folding in on
myself like,
you know,
right back.
I gotta go make Pasta.
I got to be right back.
I gotta go take five years to plant a
vineyard because the old still be right
where you were when I left.
Um,
but it's,
it's a great thing.
What they're doing is a wonderful.
I completely back what you're doing.
Uh,
no another way to do it.
There's no other way for them to do it
for me.
I can,
I can move much more quickly if you'll,
if you'll let me help you.
I've done,
you know,
I've written a few songs.
In fact,
I was involved in many of them,
um,
the ones that we've done so we could do
that,
but I think this is what the,
this is what they need to do.
Uh,
and I'm,
I'm okay with it.
I,
you know,
you got to get a little friction and
they're set to come in and,
you know,
and puff my chest out a little bit and
be aggressive and let's,
you know,
let's,
let's move guys,
let's move it.
Um,
and that worked for a minute,
uh,
and we,
we definitely make traction,
but if I were to do that every day,
it would just become a part of the
friction,
more friction rather than actually
getting anything done.
Seems like one of the biggest problems
with bands,
right?
It's just getting into personalities
together.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We're definitely very strong for very
strong personalities.
Um,
you know,
same with billy,
working with billy with perfect circle,
he gets a little forest for trees
sometimes and I'm like the guy gone
what,
step back,
look at it.
Um,
and then I'm out the door for poor guys.
Go home.
Where'd you go?
Uh,
and then,
you know,
working with Matt Mitchell and Corina
and,
and put suffer.
We all generally work with or for other
projects and other people.
So when we get together we are fucking
streamline organized.
We go,
okay,
I'll check in with the guys and tool and
go,
okay,
where are we at?
What do we got?
Are we there?
Is it like,
are we going to track tomorrow?
Because we're going to track tomorrow.
I can tell you.
Great.
Then this is,
we're going to line this up,
but if we're not going to track tomorrow
and it's going to take this much time,
well then I'm going to do this other
thing while we're telling me when that
day is,
when we're,
when we're ready to start,
when these are done,
I can take my time to write.
Um,
I mean,
in fairness,
I should take my 10 years to write
lyrics now,
but I won't do that,
but I'll hold,
I'll digest these things as quickly as I
can and,
and keep that moment,
that freshness of what my impressions
are of the finished tracks and we'll
start,
but nothing,
you know,
nothing is tracked yet.
Nothing is completely finished as a
couple of songs that I think are
finished now,
I can start working on those,
but nothing's actually recorded.
There's just all for.
They're just written.
Um,
so that leaves time so I can actually go
and work with,
uh,
with billy.
I can work with Matt,
Corrina,
um,
and,
and get other things done in the
interim.
So there's.
So there's more.
Yeah.
When you write something like say if you
have an idea,
if you're just sitting around you like,
I have a thought,
do you just sit down and you go,
okay,
this is a tool song.
This is a perfect circle song.
This is a pushover song.
Does it just like,
no,
because what I'm,
what I'm writing to is,
is the music that I'm hearing from those
people.
So that's all you write too.
I write to the music because that way
it's a unique,
it's a unique island situation.
Those,
those things are gonna.
Whenever I've tried to write,
I've had some poetry sitting over here
that I want to write and I tried to
force it onto a song for any of those
projects.
It doesn't work.
It doesn't,
it doesn't.
It doesn't seem to fit.
So you need to hear the song,
I need to hear the finished thing for
almost finished thing and then put
lyrics to it.
Yeah.
Get them,
get the melodies in place,
get the rhythm is as if I'm an
instrument.
And that how you guys did that Fibonacci
Song?
Yeah.
Wow.
That was a really unique undertaking.
How,
what,
what was the process behind that?
Like did you,
did you say hey,
it would be a nifty idea and do
something to a mathematical sequence?
Nope.
No,
that was a complete accident.
Uh,
I think it was,
I think it was Adam or justin who had
the riff and at some point they were
actually counting,
counting the riff and it ended up being
in a seven,
eight,
nine.
I think it was like a measure of seven,
a measure of a measure of nine and I'm
not sure how you would actually write
that out as a and no notation,
but,
um,
you know,
I think seven 89 is of FIBONACCI number.
I'm just that,
you know,
the actual seminar and 89 I think.
I think,
uh,
I have to look at again,
it might be nine 87.
Well,
I don't know what the fuck we're talking
about FIBONACCI sequences,
a very unique mathematical sequence that
appears in nature.
It's a,
it's in fractals,
it's in sunflowers.
If you look at the pattern of a
sunflower seeds,
if you look at nautilus shells and what
it is,
it's an expanding fractal,
sort of a mathematical equation.
I don't know if I'm saying it correctly,
but it's like the first step is zero and
then there's one and then there's one to
two posts.
Yeah.
And it just keeps going on.
So that's the,
that's the FIBONACCI number,
a whole number,
like actual number sequence.
There's the fire ratio.
One point,
one point six,
one eight,
anything multiplied by the one point six
minute that,
that are not,
not multiplied.
The relationship,
uh,
the difference,
the difference in the length from this
finger,
this finger as opposed to this finger,
that finger,
that,
those,
those knuckles and your digits,
those are all in that,
in that relationship of one point six,
one eight.
The fire relationships so that the
fractals as it's,
as it's growing,
that progression is,
uh,
is that,
is that ratio.
And then the number breakdown is,
as you said,
it's one,
one,
two,
three,
five,
eight,
13.
Yeah,
it was.
So like one plus one is two,
two plus one is three,
three plus two is five,
five plus three is eight.
And it's like everything you,
you count,
you add what came before it ended a
spiral,
a picture of like of a Giza plateau
showing you them.
Well also facial structure,
which is really fascinating.
There's something about human facial
structure that uses the FIBONACCI
sequence.
And I read somewhere about why people
recognize plastic surgery while it
disturbs them.
Boom.
Yeah.
It's like what's going on with the
sequence?
The sequence is off.
So my friend.
Yeah.
Here it is,
the FIBONACCI relationships of the human
head.
And then all A.
I had a friend who said,
you know how when you know a,
you know,
a family has had a child
who has down's syndrome,
right?
There's does,
it crosses racial divides.
It just,
you can tell this.
This family has had that,
that child has down syndrome.
There was a look that goes along with
it.
He said if the same look,
you know,
not the same look,
but like,
it's the same recognition of people who
have had a facial plastic
surgery.
You recognize you're not fooling
anybody.
You are,
you've done a thing that's recognizable
universally as wrong.
Something's wrong with your son.
Doesn't off.
Yeah,
it's off.
Yeah.
But I thought he was
funny that he was actually connecting it
to doubt.
No disrespect to people with down
syndrome.
But um,
yeah,
I know what you're saying.
Yeah.
But,
but it's like when you see someone with
a disease,
like Oh,
there's clearly an error here in the
code.
Yes.
Yeah.
And the,
and the facial reconstruction,
like the plastic surgery because I'm
just,
Oh shit,
I,
I'm getting older.
You just have them hold the nose thing
too is weird.
Like when someone has a uniquely small
nose and their face,
they might have like a long,
like Ari Shaffir type face.
But then they have this like shrunken
down knows you're like hey yeah,
this seems fucked.
Right?
So it doesn't.
There's a ratio that supposed to exist
and it doesn't exist.
But you know,
in a,
in a way a song like a lottery with the
FIBONACCI thing that's,
that's I feel like I kind of pulled a
very pedestrian sophomore move by
including those numbers in there because
in general music is the fire ratio.
Everything,
everything that all nature,
all these things.
We're talking about it.
It's already here by,
by pointing it out,
like staring at it and pointing at it.
With those numbers are present and the,
and the way that the numbers and the
lyrics are,
I feel like that,
you know,
it's good to let people know about it,
but I almost feel like it was kind of a,
it was kind of a Dick joke in a way.
It's,
it's,
um,
I could do better.
That's interesting.
Are you one of those ruthlessly
introspective guys?
Just choose.
Yeah.
Probably so obvious.
So anybody's name
good at anything.
Does that.
No other way around.
Good thing.
I'm not good at anything.
It's almost like you have a guard dog,
but you turn on yourself.
Yeah.
Sit.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
you know,
like figuring out what's wrong with me.
Get me,
get me.
And then you,
uh,
yeah.
Fly.
You're fucked.
I'm my own guard dog.
One shot to the dome.
I break the God I punched through the
guard.
My shots go through your God.
Keep your hands up.
Okay.
That's enough.
You're fucked.
Hey,
everyone's fucked yet.
But that's,
um,
that's a characteristic that I see in
almost everybody that I respect.
They all think that everything they do
socks or at least they have very,
very high standards and are often
disappointed by their own work.
Well,
you know,
I think I have some of that,
but I also have that idea of like,
it's something that might.
I don't know if I talked about my dad
with you,
but um,
he was my wrestling coach in high
school.
Uh,
he was also my,
uh,
earth science biology and environmental
studies teacher.
He was my teacher.
Well,
what a drag you went to school,
your dad being the tea does fucking.
And I learned a lot because he was no
joke.
He didn't pull any punches for me.
He,
you know,
he drove me as hard,
if not harder than of his other
students.
He didn't show any favoritism,
but one of the things that was always
his thing on the mat,
and I'm kind of paraphrasing,
but basically you,
you either win or you learn,
especially in that high school college
setting,
you're,
you're learning about yourself.
If you,
if you went out there and you got your
ass handed to you and you just got beat
and didn't learn anything,
well yeah,
you're a fucking loser.
Take the moment,
reflect on it,
build on what you did wrong and you now
you're actually gonna wave one.
Now you know more about yourself.
You know about more your.
Your limitations are what you need to
improve and expand your talents are your
limitations.
So I guess whenever I'm doing a thing,
I'm always looking at it from a learning
perspective so there aren't necessarily
mistakes unless they're fatal and then
you wouldn't know anyway.
So whatever that really is the right way
to look at everything.
When are you learn?
You know you have great experiences
because you were successful or you have
very beneficial experiences because you
realized what went wrong.
What is this one more wrinkle,
one more piece of information or
Glenmore experience that you can add to
your database of knowledge and it'll
make you better at everything.
So that,
and a lot of ways,
that's my biggest frustration in life is
when there is something that goes wrong
and I can't figure out what it was
that's frustrating for me because I
can't,
I can't build on it.
I can't learn from it,
but I don't understand what went wrong.
But what was a relationship or whether
it's something I tried to build or
something I did or how often does that
happen?
A lot.
You know,
I,
you know,
there's a couple of times I've actually
had an opportunity to do a vocal with
somebody else as a guest singer and I,
you know,
rehearsal was great and then you blew it
for the,
for the main event.
And I'm like,
what did I do wrong?
I did everything the same and until you
can actually pinpoint that and figure
out what it was,
I'm a fucking mess.
Like I'm slipping.
I'm waking up in the middle of the night
trying to figure out what the fuck went
wrong.
Yeah,
that's the same with comedy cut.
That's one flub joke or one,
one premise that you botched and just
know you'll wake up.
I'll wake up to pee and go,
fuck,
you know,
just don't have to go downstairs and get
in front of the computer and just start
writing again,
you know,
just get angry at a fix this fucking
thing.
I got to figure out what's wrong with
it.
I'm going to make it bulletproof.
Yeah.
It's um,
you're a unique guy in that you,
you're,
you're all these different things that
you're doing.
I feel like the Kinda like work
synergistically to have.
So yeah.
I don't feel like you're going.
You don't think like you're battling,
you're.
I know people that are battling
themselves,
you know,
with all the different things.
But this all feeds everything.
The stories.
I'm a storyteller,
so I'm involved in a lot of life.
I'm trying,
I'm doing things on many,
many levels because in order to tell a
full,
more complete picture,
a better story,
having more information,
a good a good actor is going to do is
research on the character beyond the
character is going to find out about the
region,
the character supposedly from and the
history of their family's history.
And you know what,
they're going to add all these things
then so that like when they had their
one line,
all that history is behind their eyes.
So I feel like that's,
you know,
for writing,
for winemaking,
they're all crossing over together.
They're all feeding each other to make
it,
to make it a whole presentation.
Yeah.
When you're managing the,
you know,
a crop of grapes and putting together a
wine and you got a restaurant going on,
you're working on your Jujitsu and then
you're writing songs,
you're living all these different
experiences.
You have so much feeding into your
consciousness.
There's so many variables that you're
attending to that it just keeps your
mind sharp and fresh and it creates
a,
not new necessarily like conflict,
but the issue is live things that need
to be figured out and solutions need to
be created for problems.
It's not like there's something that
happens to certain people.
They get too locked into one thing.
I feel that they just run out of juice.
They run out of things to discuss.
They run out of there,
run out of run out of perspective.
Yeah.
I mean you're,
you know,
during the seventies,
eighties,
a era of music coming out.
First two records are probably those
people spent the whole,
their whole lives writing those two
records and the third record is all
about the bus or the travel or the are
the shitty record label or a manager.
Like it's all the road that's the road
album because,
well where the fuck have they been for
the last three years,
but in a bus or in an airport and hotel.
So those,
those albums ended up being the ones
that either make or break the band as
far as getting past a,
those,
you know,
in general I'm speaking very generally.
Of course.
Yeah.
But it's the same with comics.
It's this with comics it's usually you
have one or two good specials and then
there's a big drop off.
You know,
I think it's guys run out of stuff to
talk about and usually you work for like
10 years before you do anything before
you release anything that the best guys,
it seems like they worked like 10,
10 years and then they put out an album
or a comedy special or whatever it is
and then you just,
your,
your life is about performing,
your life is about doing that and you
don't have enough options outside of
that.
Like a lot of comics turned to airline
jokes and you know,
things like hotels and he started
talking about that.
Like that's your experience is
constantly being on the website,
what you're exposed to.
Talk about what you know,
write what you know and that's what you
all,
you know now as a fucking delayed
flight.
But I don't know anybody else is doing
it your way.
Like rock style way also runs a
vineyard.
All it's like also regularly changes,
Jujitsu,
a Daniel day,
Lewis sorts of hats or something to make
shoes.
I have shoes.
Yeah.
Shoes.
I want a pair of Daniel Day Lewis shoes.
Isn't that what he's doing?
I feel like he's making shoes.
Well,
I don't know.
A lot of actors I've taught here have
met that have gotten on a roll with a
good series,
a TV series.
A lot of them will say the same thing,
like about a couple of seasons in.
He started looking at the door because
you're acting muscles start to atrophy
if you're only being this guy on that
show for eight years.
Do they start going crazy and going into
drugs and buying houses?
Yeah.
So you start to,
you start to get a little spiral so you
know,
to get out and be able to do a few films
a lot.
Alec William Peterson was on CSI,
the CSR forever.
He's does theater now.
Yeah,
I would think you would have to.
That's the guy from to live and die in
La.
Yup.
I forgot about that movie.
And Hunter Peep.
Yeah.
That was the original Hannibal Lecter
movie with a different Guy Than Anthony
Hopkins.
It was a great movie.
Great.
Forgotten.
Moving to live in Dianella is a
forgotten movie.
That is a great fucking movie.
Brian Cox is Dr Lecter and there he is.
Handsome faster back then.
Yeah,
look at him and he's just his sharpening
his chops on the theater stage because
a,
he's a true that guys that got the real
deal,
but he's on CSI to get paid.
Yeah,
I guess initially I think most likely
when that,
when that whole new era of TV was coming
out as it probably seemed like a good
idea for him to kind of just,
you know,
it probably had some bills to pay and he
wants you to get on their taking.
It was going to be a couple seasons.
It's just going to get out of their
contract and they're going to keep you
around if you do this,
but I want to do this theater thing.
I want to go do Shakespeare in the park
and they'll punish you if you leave too.
Yeah,
the black volume.
This motherfucker will leave a series
when it's.
Yeah,
so ruined does.
I don't know.
I don't know him.
I don't know his decisions,
but I think a speaking to a lot of
different people that have been in this
situation,
it's definitely,
yeah,
you kind of waited it out.
Like if I just stick with this thing for
six seasons,
eight seasons,
I have enough money in the bank for the
rest of my life,
you know,
uh,
and then I'll have to fight my way back
a couple of years,
uh,
of detoxing from that very.
It could be a great situation because
you have.
Well,
I think it makes people go crazy.
I think that's what happened at Johnny
Depp.
You know,
Johnny Depp when he started doing those
pirates of the Caribbean movies.
You know,
it's interesting like Johnny Depp at one
point in time and I'm,
I'm a Johnny Depp Fan.
I think he's a great actor.
Seems like a wild dude.
He's buddies with my friend Stan hope
and standup loves him,
so he's got to be a good guy.
Have a lot of mutual friends.
I've never actually,
I met him a long,
long,
long time ago,
but I don't,
I don't.
Yeah.
He used to do these weird projects,
strange movies,
and he.
He even said once,
I don't want to be blockbuster.
Blockbuster boy.
Yeah,
dead man.
That black and white.
Yeah.
That black and white western Arizona
dream checked that one out.
That's right.
Yeah.
Fantastic.
He did a lot of really cool,
weird projects and then he did the
pirates of the Caribbean and that
fucking group of movies has been so
wildly successful that he's just made
ungodly amounts of money to the point
where he was spending so much fucking
money.
They had some breakdown because he's
involved in some lawsuit with his former
manager there.
As soon as former manager,
he was spending $150,000
a month on private security.
Twenty four hours a day,
spending $200,000
a month on private jets and they're just
going on and on and on.
He had a staff of 40 people.
He managed fund.
No Johnny Depp.
Johnny Depp.
A staff of 40 people,
something
like 15 different homes all over the
world.
Just Paul
went out of control too,
so balling out of control.
Korean fulcan corner.
Not we could bring him in.
Now.
What is this among his mobile six
traveling expenses listed in a
countersuit where $3,000,000
spent to blast hunter Thompson's ashes
out of a cannon and $30,000
a month spend on wine.
The New York Post Gossip column.
Page six report.
Yeah.
Well they're the same concept.
Said that Ronda Rousey and Travis Browne
are washed up losers.
Yeah.
I don't know if they're right.
What does this house they're showing?
Hey though,
let's talk about paid blow up like the
world trade Johnny Depp Chateau in the
south of France.
Who buys the shot to have a restaurant
with an awning and a logo on it.
That doesn't even make sense.
Does it have his own restaurant?
How ball or they're overthinking it?
Maybe it's a restaurant.
Yeah,
but I mean like for himself only.
He shows up a table for two.
Sir,
can I get on the list?
Strange character.
He's a strange character.
I think that's what happened.
He started buying all that shit when he
got that pirates of the Caribbean money
because you don't really want to be Jack
Sparrow every fucking day.
Like I want to do something else.
You can't do something else.
And every time he does something else,
it just doesn't really work.
It doesn't really work like the pirates
of the Caribbean guide does,
you know,
like how many different movies is he
done since you've done the pirates of
the Caribbean?
Couple.
Couple?
Yeah,
that's right.
He did Edward Scissorhands.
Oh No,
he did the Alice in wonderland thing
since the pirates of the Caribbean.
That was actually really good.
It was weird.
I enjoyed it,
but I enjoyed it.
Yeah.
Well they want go.
There's a lot of weird shit.
Anyway,
point being,
they go crazy.
They just start.
They start spending,
buying stopped buying and spending to
get caught now where?
Howard Hughes and a downward spiral.
What does this movie tonto and the lone
ranger.
That's right.
The 10 worst Johnny Depp movie.
Wasn't that a guy that died and came
back to life or something like that or
he had the lone ranger come back to life
and it helped him come back to life
comes back to life or something.
I think that's cultural appropriation
because I don't believe that he's
Indian,
so I'm offended.
How come they couldn't get a native
American Indian?
Yeah,
that's A.
Yeah.
I have a hard time with all that.
I'm know what.
So.
Okay.
You have you own guns?
Yes.
Okay.
But you're,
you know,
you're a pot smoker,
a your.
Would you consider yourself a liberal?
A more liberal than I am conservative
for sure.
Okay.
So there's,
there's that balance.
Um,
you think the make ribs like that,
you know,
don't call me.
I would like to be now from out,
you know,
I'm,
I'm an,
I'm an avocado,
I relate to avocado.
So as my,
my sexuality,
I relate to an avocado.
So.
And don't think you're allowed to
identify as an avocado now.
Okay.
So that,
that thing just,
you know,
there's,
again,
we need a meteor I guess when it comes
to talking about guns and avocado,
but like you know,
just that whole the politically correct
thing,
but then the anti electric intellectual
ism that comes from what I would
consider the lower.
Right?
Yeah,
there's a far right that it does go anti
intellectual ism and then there's far
left that even though they might be more
well read and maybe intellectual,
they put up these blinders to a certain
patterns of thinking as well.
I mean there's,
there's not a lot of like across the
board objectivity,
there's a lot of people formulating
these preformed patterns of opinions
that conservative opinions and just
clinging to it or liberal opinions and
cleaning to it.
I think there's no gray area.
Yeah,
I think most people media lots of gray.
A lot of gray area.
Yeah.
Meteor.
I think most people really share like
ideas that are conservative and liberal
and I think what's really important,
we should be able to discuss these ideas
without digging our heels and just being
fully committed to one team or the other
team.
That's where the problem lies.
People would so tribal,
whether it's conservative or liberal,
even libertarian,
they go real tribal and they just like
lock onto those ideas and this is right
and that is wrong and you know,
and it just.
People don't want.
They don't want to give in and so then
they fight and they dig their heels in
and they know they fight their opinion.
I'm an arm snowflake.
Is that,
is that a new category?
You could do that.
Yeah.
Should be able to do that.
Why not?
So who could stop you from being an
snowflake?
You have bullets and shit.
You know,
regular snowflakes don't have bullets.
Superman.
I think,
man,
I think we're,
we're moving into a new stage of
humanity is as profound and ridiculous
and you know,
verbose as that sounds.
I really think that's what's going on
and I think all this in fighting and
squabbling is we're trying to find our
footing,
trying to figure out what we are and
what we're doing and guns are part of
that.
It's like,
should you be allowed to just have that?
Like I don't know.
Every now and then it goes wrong.
Well,
if it goes wrong,
what do you want to be able to protect
yourself?
Yeah,
you got a point.
No,
you don't have a point.
No one should have one you have,
but what about when the bad people come?
Should you have one then?
No,
she just let the bad people will kill
you and then it's all bad people.
I've had the good people are dead.
Well who's that?
Who's to determine what.
If a person gets a hold of it and they
do a bad thing,
like there's all these variables but I,
I don't think.
I don't think it's that cut and dry and
I also think it's a lot like everything
else here.
Media or maybe what part if you were
looking at a part of the world without
pissing anybody off without,
without pissing anybody off,
we're not going to care.
There's like a billion people so we lost
a half a million fucking mouth.
It would have to wipe out like lot via
like okay,
boom.
And then
baird or like have you seen,
did you,
had you watched the leftovers?
Yes,
I watched the first episode.
Yeah,
it's,
I,
I like,
you know,
I think the I love,
I love,
I love watching actors,
actors,
flexor their missile.
I love it.
So I love that series because you get
better after the first episode that
looks set in a bunch of stuff up.
Yeah,
I mean as a lot of setup,
but just the concept right away,
storyteller.
I love the a good story.
A huge percentage of the population just
fucking vanishes with no explanation.
I'm in.
I'm in and all the psychological and all
the religious stuff that unfolds and
collapses and builds up and freaks out
based on that.
I think if we're going to do something
like that,
uh,
it would have to be spontaneous
combustion from a percentage of the
globe across the board.
No,
no,
no.
There's burst into flames.
Yeah.
That's a real thing.
If five percent of the population
spontaneously combusting at the same
time across the globe in front of
people.
And no explanation,
no explanation.
Now we're going to talk.
I don't think that's enough.
I think it's gotTa.
Something's gotta hit us because then
you'd be like,
well,
obviously camp,
you want to see people maybe
fuck you and fuck your hits.
I'm all for people at Penn and spuntech
member when we're kids.
Like spontaneous combustion was a thing
he would wonder,
maybe one of your friends will burst
into flames while you're in school.
They they're lighting farts or something
that real spontaneous human combustion.
Is it truly real?
I don't know how spontaneous human
combustion works can make that a little
bigger so I can read it.
And December 19,
66,
the body of a 96 year old dr j Dot
Irving Bentley would discovered in his
Pennsylvania home by a meter reader,
actually only part of Dr.
Bentley's leg and slippered foot were
found.
The rest of his body had been burned to
ashes.
A hole in the bathroom floor was the
only evidence of the fire that had
killed him.
The rest of the house remained perfectly
intact.
How could a man catch fire with no
apparent source of a spark or flame and
then burns so completely without
igniting anything around him said the
Washington Post?
Yeah,
Dr.
Bentley's case in several hundred others
like it have been labeled spontaneous
human combustion,
although he and other victims of the
phenomena burned almost completely their
surroundings and the even sometimes
they're close remained virtually
untouched.
Well,
that's just fucking bullshit.
Who?
What website is this?
Listen Bitch.
If you're on fire,
you're fucking clothes are going to
catch fire too.
Unless someone's using pixie magic on
you or they did.
You get hit with a magic wand wielded by
an Elf.
You've cut your fucking clothes are
gonna burn stupid.
If you're burning,
your clothes are burning.
This is horseshit sciences.
Okay?
If spontaneous human combustion isn't
real,
then what?
Really to the many pictures that exist
of charred bodies,
a possible explanation is the wick
effect which produces proposes that the
body when lit by a cigarette smoldering
ember or other heat source acts,
much like an inside out candle,
a candle is composed of a wick on the
inside surrounded by a wax made of
flammable fatty acids.
The wax ignites the wick and keeps it
burning in the human body.
The body's fat acts as a flammable
substance,
and the victim's clothing or hail here
acts as the wic.
As the fat melt from the heat.
It's soaks into the clothing and acts as
a wax like substance to keep the wick
burning.
Slowly.
Scientists say,
this is why the victims bodies are
destroyed,
yet their surroundings are barely burnt.
Whoa,
so they're so fat that we become like a
big greasy candle says no one's.
No one's ever conclusively proven or
disproven the truth,
spontaneous human combustion,
but most scientists say that there are
more likely explanations for the charred
remains like your wife fucking hates
you.
She hates you in the head with a frying
pan.
Let your ass on fire through you in the
tub and say,
I don't even know what happened.
I think it's one of them.
Ripley's believe it or not thing,
and then you know,
she seen in the embrace of the hardware
store manager.
I was crying and Stanley help me
watching the tick.
I don't think it's real.
I cried bullshit.
That's why,
and that's why it would make so much
more of an impact if it happened to five
percent of the population.
I think an outside threat,
if another planet like an impact is like
a wakeup call and outs,
like spontaneous seeming alien showed up
and started shooting people from
spaceships,
everyone's going to go,
that's bullshit.
That's the government.
Could be right,
but an asteroid,
you realize the government cannot
recreate something the size of a city.
It's slamming into the planet.
That's what going to happen.
Yeah,
but it's weird
care.
We care in a big way how people die,
right?
Like nine slash 11 was huge because
people caused 3000 people to die and the
world changed radically because of those
3000 deaths.
But half a million people die every year
because of cigarettes.
A half a million just in this country
alone.
And we're like,
yeah,
yeah.
Whatever.
Like it doesn't bother us.
Like you die that way.
Well your die.
I'm
choking on your,
on pus filled lungs in some sort of
urgent care center.
That doesn't bother us as much.
Like,
that's Ah,
I shouldn't have smoked,
but you get caught in the 500th floor of
some fucking skyscraper and get hit in
the face.
There's a,
there's some good.
There's a lot of good books on those
kinds of things that,
that,
uh,
just,
you know,
something like the Holocaust in general,
just the intent and the focus and the
hatred toward a specific group of people
has way more than the cigarette.
The cigarette smoke,
the cigarettes don't have,
they're not angry.
They're not hateful,
so that death is not.
It doesn't,
you don't.
It doesn't hurt you as much as if you
had the,
the impact of a group of people hating
another group of people so much that
they,
they killed them in a mass,
you know,
on a massive event.
It's kind of insidious though,
if you really look at it objectively,
look,
it's okay as long as they peacefully
suck the vitality of your body with
chemical dip plants wrapped in paper
that they trick you into sucking on.
Once you light them on fire and your
body becomes accustomed and addicted to
it.
And we're like,
hey,
it's a,
it's a stress relieving choice.
Great.
Don't smoke too much.
Just as long as you only smoke a little.
That'd be fun.
What are the statistics?
It's that like secondhand.
Secondhand is bad to people,
waitresses and stuff,
and in bars they would get,
a lot of them will get cancer and people
that lived with people that were chronic
smokers,
but they weren't smokers themselves.
A lot of them got cancer.
Secondhand smoke,
especially in a small enclosed area is
real as fuck.
It's not as bad as the cigarettes
themselves,
but we should have seen the first clue
would have been like as soon as they
soon as they pulled smoking off of
planes like,
oh,
that must be a problem to the planes are
riddick because you're having to pay for
some flight attendants.
Cancer.
Yeah.
That would be why those things were
ridiculous.
I remember they used to smoke in the
back end.
If you smoking non nonsmoking section
separated by space,
that's it.
Separated and a tube.
Second hand smoke causes approximately
7,333
deaths from lung cancer and 33,950
deaths from heart disease every year and
64 and 2014 to two point $5.
Million people died from exposure to
secondhand smoke,
so it's not quite as bad.
It's about,
you know,
20,000
as opposed to 500,000,
but still it's terrible lot.
Yeah.
It's not as bad,
but it's still fucking terrible.
It's weird.
He's not a.
he's like searching.
What do,
what are you doing?
Well,
we're not talking about.
Sorry.
Are you constantly on his phone?
Hey Siri,
what's going on with satellites?
Are they real?
Hey Siri.
What's up with that?
ICEFALL and Erica.
Big Chunks of.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
There's a fucking chunk of ice that they
had been monitoring.
A glacier.
That's the biggest glacier of the world
has ever known is the size of Delaware
and it's floating around in the ocean
now.
It is so unbelievably massive.
You could be standing on this glacier
and not see the end of it.
You wouldn't see how far it goes and
it's floating in this iceberg,
I should say.
It's floating.
It broke off.
10 things that are smaller than this
iceberg.
Jesus Christ.
It's so
big.
It's Grand Canyon.
The Grand Canyon is smaller.
The Great Salt Lake is smaller.
Long Island is smaller Luxembourg.
A smaller lake.
Okeechobee in Florida is smaller.
Los Angeles is smaller than this fucking
iceberg lake champlain in New York as
smaller New York City is smaller than
this fucking earthquake or earthquake.
This iceberg that.
That's a sane.
So it's separated.
Do they have a satellite image of this
thing?
It's separated and floated off and it's
going to come slamming right into the
Santa Monica pier that you could see it
as they fly over it.
Oh my God.
Look at that photo.
That's fucking insane.
The photo is a.
someone took it from a plane.
You're looking down with the wings and
where was it?
Was it in Greenland?
Where were to break off and Arctica.
Arctica.
Is that the ice wall?
Which separates us and flatter.
There's all these assholes and so you
can't fly over Antarctica online.
You absolutely can.
You piece of shit.
Not only that,
Anthony Bourdain just filmed a show from
there.
He was in Antarctica.
You dumped cons.
He filmed the show.
You landed in Antarctica.
He talked to the people that work in the
science department there.
Whatever the fuck they do,
running experiments.
Try and keep the Russians from invading
all that.
Yeah,
get them up to.
We should get up to jerome.
Jerome.
Yeah,
let's get them to come try the wine or
take them out of the vineyards and we
have to training to with him.
Huh?
I think it'd be a good,
a good show to combine them.
The wine,
the pasta,
the,
the local food.
I sense competitive aggression from,
you know,
you're sensing that because you're
projecting it.
No,
no,
I'm good.
No,
I think think track anymore.
I'm not that guy in a bar at a thousand
dollars glass of wine.
That to definitely get them up there and
get them some good.
He would do it for sure.
He would film at your place.
It'd be a good thing to do.
Maybe I could helped orchestrate that.
That'd be a dopey,
dopey,
a dove.
That'd be a Dopa episode for a show,
you know.
And you also have a very unique story
too,
like doing your thing out there in
Arizona and look man,
for him it's an opportunity to do some
Jujitsu.
That guy's an addict.
He does it every day.
Yeah.
He's amazing.
When we were in Montana,
we filmed an episode of his show.
He went to a.
maybe it was Bozeman,
I think it was Bozeman.
He just found some local Jujitsu club
was rolling with these guys.
He didn't even know him.
He gets in there and started training
with him.
He's an animal.
That's awesome.
He doesn't fuck around.
He does it out overseas to like one 80.
Well,
he's very tall.
I think he's like at least six,
three and he's thin.
He's lost a ton of weight.
He lost 30 pounds from doing Jujitsu.
He was on all sorts of WHO's on statens
for high blood,
high
cholesterol because of his diet and
sedentary lifestyle and you know,
he's like,
well,
you know,
I have the choice between changing what
I eat right and I don't want to do that.
I want to keep eating pork and all these
delicious foods or taking these stat.
And so we just decided to take the
statens,
but once he started training Jujitsu,
he got off all that shit.
Yeah.
Just his body just responded to the
demands.
Yeah.
Your body responds to the demands,
you know?
I think that's one of the,
an unheralded factors in people's
obesity is not just the Diet,
which is a huge factor for sure,
but also the requirements that you're
asking of your body.
Only the bodies are not used to sitting
around doing nothing.
Go to get up,
go to get,
go.
We'd go off to a cat.
Can I ask you a question?
Yes,
please do.
What's the,
what's the Hollywood Babylon,
but over a what happened with Nuñez?
Well,
she got something called sinus status.
She has apparently like severe sinus
infections that affect our balance and
they get really bad and um,
she got one the day of the weigh ins.
She made it through the weigh ends and
then she was having like a serious
episode to the point where they checked
her into the hospital and the word was
that she wanted to compete,
but her coaches did not want her to
compete.
They're,
look,
you're having like a really hard time,
like walking,
like apparently when your sciences get
like really inflamed,
it fucks with your equilibrium.
Inner ear.
Yeah.
This is second and third hand by the
way.
I didn't talk to her.
Right.
And uh,
you know,
that's what you'd have to do.
You'd have to have her talk about it,
but it's super unfortunate because that
was,
in my opinion,
was the highest level women's mma bout
ever in terms of the overall ability of
the two athletes.
I think Valentina Shevchenko and Amanda
Nunez,
they represent the peak.
These are the,
this is the best we've ever seen.
Yeah.
Nunez is a ruthless knockout striker.
She beat the shit out of Ronda Rousey
and she choked the shit out of me.
She takes,
she's a real legit black belt in
Brazilian Jujitsu,
knockout stryker.
And then volunteership Chanko is a
Moitai champion.
Ridiculous.
Stand up.
And you know,
she caught Julianna Pena with an arm bar
from the guard.
Like her ground game is nasty to me.
Penny is legit for her to catch penny
with an arm bars.
That's staggering.
And her striking is so good.
Like you saw in the Holly Holm fight,
she shot Holly Holm down,
whereas like,
I mean,
Holly Holm fucked up Jermaine to Rhonda,
me with a question mark.
Kick dropped her with a straight left
hand.
She never had close to that kind of
success against Valentina.
Valentina is super high level with her
striking her movement.
She fights southbound.
She has that beautiful check right hook
that she throws that like keeps
everybody minding their p's and q's.
She's at a super well rounded game,
so it's really unfortunate that those
two didn't go at it,
but that was going to be a good fight.
I think they're going to schedule it
again for the.
The event that is after the end of July
event,
I think it's 2:15.
They're going to schedule it for sure.
But then you know,
like Dana White said,
now Amanda Nunez would never headline in
the van again and I just don't think you
can force someone to fight if she really
did have a significant injury.
Like they said that the doctors cleared
her to fight,
you know,
a significant illness I should say.
She,
she,
they said the doctors cleared to fight,
but she chose not to the company word,
but if she's like,
was that fucked up?
I just can't imagine she wasn't that
fucked up.
I mean,
it's got to suck.
Have you spent millions of dollars
promoting a fight and then here it is
and then people bought the paper view
and then it falls apart and you got to
give refunds and I don't know.
Yeah.
Well welcome to welcome to the music
industry.
When it was at its peak in the nineties
when people are like writing big checks
for stuff and like,
oh yeah,
this is going to begin to get mariah
carey for millions of dollars.
Here's the thing.
And then she goes and she has a
meltdown.
She went crazy peers.
Yeah.
And then like the like what did we just
spend our money on?
What happened just now?
A mariah carey go crazy.
What happened?
I don't know.
I think she had a meltdown.
One of those.
Maybe she got a bad dick.
Wow.
I wonder if you catch a bad dick while I
have never personally.
I've never caught a bad dick.
So Dick,
I have.
Not that I'm aware of.
Big Dick it kitchen ambivalent.
I have not caught him.
Ambivalent Dick.
Yeah.
I keep going.
I mean I might.
There might be one in there somewhere.
I wonder.
I wonder,
I mean,
it's got,
it's got to be a way.
Yeah.
I don't know,
but you know,
somebody wrote a big check.
You have an artist who had a meltdown,
didn't deliver because that's you're
talking about were we are merchants of
emotion.
That's what we do.
And sometimes it can overwhelm you.
That is an old,
that is a volatile thing.
Um,
and it's story as old as time and you
know,
with fighters,
one little dump thick walking up the
stairs to the octagon,
he can pull know your acl fucking
separates from your body.
Yeah.
You could slip you.
Kevin Randleman was backstage preparing
for a fight once and he stepped on a
pipe and slipped and fell on his head
and was concussed.
Yeah,
right
before the main event,
right before the main event,
he was walking backstage.
He stepped on something,
slipped his leg,
went up on,
he hit his fucking head and he was
concussed and they canceled the fight.
Yeah.
That was like a myth.
I want to say that was in 1997 or 1998
or somewhere around there and it just
like,
what?
Yeah,
that can happen for sure.
And then for a fighter,
there's so much about who they are is
dependent upon their confidence and
their state of mind and if she hears
that the UFC is pissed at her,
she had to pull out of the fight and
then they say that they'll never have
her headline and event again.
I when she goes from being this
superstar with two spectacular
performances against the most popular
women's fighters of all time,
those two,
between Misha tate and Ronda Rousey,
I would say arguably the most popular
women fighters of all time.
Coincidentally,
they're both the hottest.
How weird.
You know,
like you got to see if you're going to
be a chicken,
you got to be a fighter.
It's,
it helps a lot if you're hot,
doesn't it?
I am not hot and I'm not a chip.
I noticed both of those things.
I didn't want to bring it up though.
I didn't want to rub your face in it.
Right.
But uh,
yeah,
I mean she's.
Who knows how she's going to bounce back
from.
That sucks.
It sucks with Valentine at too,
right?
She gets through the weigh ins,
she gets through the weight cut,
she gets to the training at home.
Home is one on a in Singapore.
That was a wonderful.
That was great.
Balm.
Yeah.
She that question mark kick that same
kick she throws.
That kicks so well.
That's a sneaky ass fucking kick man.
When you think it's going to be a round
kick to the body or a low kick and then
it comes up high and clangs you in the
dome.
Yeah.
It's so good the way they throw that too
because it comes in like this and that
loops over clang.
She might be the best in the world at it
in an MMA.
Luke rockhold is got a really good one
too.
He used it against bisping and their
first fight.
They.
They throw it and it's such an unusual
motion of a kick.
It looks like it's coming up and then it
just goes whip over the top,
pull up.
Luke rockhold Kaos.
Michael Bisping.
He actually dropped him with it and then
he caught him with a guillotine choke
afterwards and tapped him with a gay
teen,
but the way he throws that kick his
fucking super sneaky.
Who's coming up?
There's some.
There's a Maya fight coming up in there.
Yeah.
I'm UFC 199.
Is this the right one?
Is this the one when he won or is this
the one?
I'm not sure.
This is the one where bisping Kaos him.
Yeah.
See right there.
Yeah,
go to the first one.
Their first fight.
Their first fight is the one.
He choked him out.
He didn't kill him,
but he a clang them with the question
mark kick.
Yeah.
Don't go with Kao
versus Bisping One.
Yeah,
Guillotine.
Here it is.
You got jacked?
Yeah.
This is some guy holding up a camera.
I did it,
man.
The UFC takes a lot of those things
down.
I think rockhold guillotine choke.
First Time bisping taps.
Yeah.
This is it.
Because he was wearing a beard at the
time.
Interesting.
They fought two times,
you know,
and then rockhold thought it was going
to be an easy fight.
The second time and he got fucked up.
I think it's right before that.
I don't know.
It's hard to tell.
But anyway,
so it's such an unusual movement.
What is this?
Just a bunch of highlights.
There it is right there.
But they don't show the whole kick.
They just show that the actual end of it
as it's landing,
Eh,
whatever.
You have to show it.
Point being holly has got one of the
best.
She's.
She's interesting because she's a
combination of a boxer.
She was like a world champion boxer.
I think like times world champion boxer,
but she also has like traditional karate
techniques.
It's throws like a lot of side kicks in
like these weird round kicks.
Yeah.
She keep eyes when she throws shots.
Yeah,
there it is.
Cut Climbing.
Yeah.
And that was after bench go.
Hey,
I was kind of like taunting her.
Oopsies.
Yeah.
That high kick man,
that left high kick.
That's her highlight reel movement.
That's the one that separated Rousey.
You can eat crap
for our uh,
our um,
arsonist video for me and my me fighting
Ronda Rousey.
No,
no good.
No good.
No one gave me a hard time,
know
no holly or any of these guys and they
were,
you know,
they were the fantastic five and there I
wasn't sure like might come out like you
do realize I'm a trump supporter.
Like,
Oh crap.
No.
Everybody thought it was funny.
It looked it didn't.
You got the,
you got away with that one maybe,
but maybe now that we're talking about
people are going to review it because
the standards over the last two months
has probably changed and people decided
more things are offensive now that we're
then yeah,
hurry up,
get on that because uh,
you know,
yell at me about that.
People are super uptight about what is
offensive and what isn't offensive.
And it moves.
It moves like the tide.
It comes in,
it comes out.
There it is.
Hey,
you can play it.
I'm going to play the whole thing.
How long,
how many minutes?
Is it time spent training for minutes?
I don't know.
The vertical hole victorious.
And with my junk intacct people,
we know how good Rhonda is.
This could be epic
Joe Rogan.
Not to be confused with
conor Mcgregor.
You gave Rhonda Rousey a very manly
appearance.
Nothing at the store.
What's going on here?
Having a lunch
specific diet for people at home were
watching animation.
If you're just listening,
Rhonda is hitting the speed bag right
now.
Looking very angry.
Commanders taking steroids and maynard
shooting stairs and it was a bad ass
because I don't.
I don't want to lose my job.
I like how you have tents.
Why'd you decide to have Ted's?
Oh,
you got a problem with that?
No,
I don't.
Just on men.
I feel like it's a gender appropriation.
It might be.
It is.
So man with tits,
if you don't claim transgender,
I got yelled at like what do you have
against people that are transgender?
Like you know you're giving up your
junk.
If you lose to Rhonda,
like that's a bad thing.
It's okay in a bag.
Here's how it works.
You have something that you want to hang
onto and keep.
Right?
I have something I want to hang onto a
keep,
whether it's money or whatever,
and the bet is
that if you lose,
you have to give up the thing that you
want to keep.
You don't.
You don't lose a bet and then give up
something you were willing to get rid of
anyway.
Of course.
So if you're a person who doesn't want
your junk,
just that's the choice you've made,
then don't.
That's not really a bet,
but if you.
If you're a person who wants to hang
onto your junk and you bet your junk
away,
that's I want my junk.
Nope,
no disrespect to Mary.
Who does not want their junk?
You want to give away?
If you want to cut your shit off,
that's fine.
I don't care,
but I want.
I would like to keep my job.
That's what my wife,
my wife wants me to keep my junk.
I think that's a really reasonable
request.
And this,
in this video you made Donald Trump to
be a giant monster that must be put down
trump's Zilla.
Now,
do you worry that like the,
what they call now,
the Kathy Griffin effect?
Could possibly happen.
People get ahold of this video.
I think that you were.
My career was over a long time.
I don't think her career is over.
I just think it's shifted.
It's shifted.
It's moved to a different place.
While she's universally hated by the
right.
She wasn't before she,
you know,
she was just kind of Kathy Griffin.
Now she's like enemy of the state.
It's just her trying to be relevant and
it didn't work.
Yeah,
exactly right.
That's exactly what it was.
Who is this one with?
The Demon said it was supposed to be
Misha tape,
but I was trying to be kind.
Oh,
so you turn turned into a demon instead
because she came out and supported
trump.
So I was gonna I was gonna throw under
the bus.
Yeah.
She made some statements earlier,
like around that time.
Really.
But I was like,
you know what?
I'm not.
She might have meant something else.
So I made them because it used to have
her name under her.
There was her know as the trump minyan.
I like how the hair is all crazy.
You get underneath the hair.
It's like scalp.
But comes over the top and crushes you
from two bald guys.
Don't you want to just talk to them
about that hair and go,
dude,
you are wasting so much time and effort
on that disaster you're keeping on top
of your head.
But it doesn't.
Again,
it might be just a part of the part of a
thing like it just keep that going.
Like the don king thing.
Like it's all part of like he's got to
know people have better haircuts than
him.
Right?
Yeah.
But he doesn't care,
right.
Maybe part of the whole you're to do it.
Do it.
Like make it look like a hat for.
We'll have.
Yeah.
It's part of the whole.
Patrick's spraying everything down and
locking it in place.
Oh you.
She got your balls in a jar that's very
triggering.
That triggers you trot was problematic.
You got to be careful these days.
Men can have balls in a jar and make it
seem like it's a bad thing.
If someone identifies with the type of
person that wants to have their balls in
a jar.
How do you feel about Trans Racial
people?
Meteor.
We need all of you.
I need a meter for all of you.
Everybody.
Where does it hit?
If you,
uh,
if.
Okay,
let's say if you're God,
you're making.
You're gonna.
Make me say where it's going to hit it
at.
Where's it go?
That does the most.
Uh,
how big is it?
Huge.
Five miles.
Five miles along with kill everybody.
That's what killed the dinosaurs.
We need like a football field sized
media,
like a hundred north 100 yards north.
Paul's not good enough.
Paul's going to cause affects around all
of their shores below it.
Interesting.
Let's look at the world.
Where do we hit it?
I'm looking at China,
Bro.
I feel like they can take the hit.
I feel like they need a solution anyway.
They've got a real problem.
There's a billion people over there.
So you're saying it has to be a
populated area?
Yeah,
but maybe like weird.
Like maybe you,
Lynne,
like right where they eat the dogs.
Maybe we go to the dog festival just and
then like everybody goes,
hey man,
maybe you shouldn't eat dogs.
God decided to hurl a media and all
those assholes that are killing people's
pets.
They're killing.
What if it's five slightly smaller
meteors and they hit every like most
continents.
That's not a bad idea,
but I think we need one big one and I
think that you.
Lynn takes the hit.
I was watching these videos where they
were capturing dogs,
stealing people's pets and they're
cooking them.
Suck.
Boy meet.
Yeah,
let's go near there.
Let's just put it there.
That's the spot.
That's just put it where they make the
dog meat like Grad as they're cooking up
the dog eat dog.
She's picking,
which I probably should go pick the hot
dog man.
What's up?
I gotta get my.
Took my dog to the groomer.
Did you really?
Oh yeah.
You took your dog out here.
Did you drive or do you fly?
I fly.
I flew.
Do you put your dog in the bottom with
the regular dogs?
She's,
she's with me.
So she sits with you?
Yeah.
Now do you have to make sure that the
person next to you is in gravely?
Uh,
allergic to dogs who have to make sure
you fuck them,
fuck them,
but you have to tell the airline,
hey,
I'm traveling with my emotional support
dog because I'm very fragile.
dog because in theory,
perhaps this might have happened to
someone that we might know.
You're getting on an airline and they
look at your.
You're paying for a dog to go on the
flight,
right?
I'm paying extra for the dog to go on
the flight.
Sir.
Does your dogs thing fit under the seat
in front of you?
Is it fit?
Yes,
it's,
it's regulation is what you want under
the seat in front of you.
Great.
Ooh,
your other bag is too big,
but that's my,
that's my carry on bag.
Yeah.
But now that you're bringing a dog on,
that is your carry on bag and that bag
you have doesn't fit under the seat in
front of you,
which is where my dog is going to be.
Right.
So what do you do?
So you had the choice.
I had to check the bag.
So you checked the bag and the dog stays
under the seat,
but the dog doesn't really fit under the
seat.
Yeah,
she's 11 pounds.
She's small,
but he kinda like stuffer into that
crack where the laptop bag goes.
Really small dogs in Yorkie.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
So the point is that if I had,
if I had a personal item that goes in,
if that goes under the seat in front of
me and the rolling bag goes up in that
upper space that you have paid for,
right?
Uh,
but they're telling me like,
no,
the dog is now the,
the carry on bag,
but I'm not.
So you want me to put my dog in the
overhead bin?
No,
it has to go into the seat in front of
you.
But you told me that carry on bags go in
the overhead bin.
It's all just like red tape.
Catch 22 crap.
But as your dog have an Esa,
is it an emotional support animal?
It can be.
Does it have to be?
Yeah.
Because if you had that,
then we don't charge you anything and
you can actually bring on all three of
those items,
dog your carry on and your personal life
and bring three bags on if your dogs and
emotional support animal.
So if you're not.
So luckily for me,
I can't fly without my dog.
Oh,
okay.
I get it.
I think Natasha has that deal to Natasha
Leggiero.
She was an emotional support dog.
Yeah,
that's a.
that's a gross loophole and I applaud
you for capitalizing on it.
So way to go.
Unless you're sitting next to someone
who's like,
I need a moment.
Yeah,
man.
Get your collector motions.
The dogs aren't even here to support
you.
How do you get through it?
I,
I pretend that the American Werewolf in
London with my dog.
That's a good move.
Good move.
Yeah.
I feel like a dog by proxy.
It's weird.
Isn't a weird thing that,
that was never around.
We were a kid.
That's why I had to pull this out.
Emotional support because you're fucking
weak.
Your mind is weak and you're fucked.
You're fucked.
You can't even go to the fucking
starbucks without bringing your dog in
with you.
I think you're allowed to do that.
I mean,
that's.
I think that's part of it.
Like if you had the paperwork,
you can go in to play anywhere that
you're not supposed to have it.
There's a restaurant that I go to that
one of those ladies used to be hot back
in the day and that she used to be on
that desperate housewives show.
Now she's kind of getting up there in
the years and getting a little wackier
and wacky.
I'm sure as time goes on,
she brings in a full grown golden lab.
This silly bitch.
His dog is like sitting down where
everybody's forks codes,
dirty assholes touching the ground where
people accidentally dropped their spoon.
It's just.
It's such a big dog.
It's so gross.
It was like something about a little dog
sitting in someone's lap at a restaurant
that's like,
it seems stupid,
but maybe not so bad,
but a lab fucking 70 pound big ass dog
laying on the ground and it's crazy.
Bitch is putting everybody else imposing
her situation on everybody else.
She knows it's not.
So do you that people that go down that,
and I think actors do this,
that go down that hardcore ketogenic
diet that they cut all the carbs out of
their diet sugars.
Do you think it's starts to,
if they do it long enough to start to
get a little dinky,
it could happen.
Definitely.
Um,
you get the Keto flu when you first
started out.
I definitely got that can push people
over the top,
but you got to do it smart.
Can't work out too hard when you first
start doing it and you got to take
exogenous ketones.
That's a big,
big.
That's helped me a tremendous amount.
What it,
what the fuck did he just say,
exoneration as ketones?
Ladies and gentlemen,
there's a bunch of different companies.
The one I use is called key genics.
They have a new one called eugenics
prime.
It's apparently even better,
but what it is is,
uh,
it's,
um,
Kama Sutra to bunch of amino acids and
minerals and stuff that puts your body
into a state of ketosis.
And it,
uh,
it allows you to balance out,
it's like,
it's very good to balance out,
gives you energy when you're sort of
struggling through that Keto flu thing
and then eventually body adapts body
gets used to burning fat and then it
just seems like it has more energy when
you do that.
But to really truly be effective,
don't you hit that kind of work out two
hours a day to really make it?
No,
no,
no.
You could definitely make it flip
without working out that much.
You don't have to work it out that much.
You just,
your body has to realize like,
okay,
carbs aren't coming in.
We're going to need to burn fats,
which it has as a sort of a go to way
like we've been eating fats and people
have been relying on fats forever.
It's not a negative thing.
Like people have this idea that the
brain relies only on.
You have any kind of carbs at all.
You had to get past a certain amount of
time or like these are people have just
given that up forever.
No,
you can have some carbs.
Your body has a certain amount of
flexibility to it,
but the way they've done it well,
here's a perfect example of how much
biodiversity or this when it comes to
your body's ability to absorb
carbohydrates and how it reacts.
I'm Rob Wolf who was a a,
a a scientist and a big paleo researcher
guy.
He's got an interesting instagram page
and on his,
I think it's Das.
Robb wolf is instagram,
but what he does is he'll eat something
and they'll have his wife eat something
and then they'll do these tests,
blood tests to find out where their
ketones are and whether or not they're
in a ketogenic state and his body's way
more fragile in terms of like it's
getting knocked off a ketosis.
Then his wife's body,
his wife just rebounds.
Better choices,
better genetics for it.
So it's pretty cool.
You know,
they obviously lived together eating the
same foods,
so it's,
there's a lot of variables involved in
how your body processes carbs and it
could,
you know,
it's like some people have celiacs,
some people are gluten sensitive,
some people,
you know,
some people have no problem eating a big
bowl of rice and they stay in Ketosis
and with some people that just knocks
them right out of it and the body goes
right back to burning carbs.
It depends also on how strict you've
been in the Ketogenic Diet and how long
you've done
it for free,
but there's a lot of critics of that
diet too.
There's a lot of people that cry
bullshit on that.
I don't know if they're crying.
I think some of the people that cry
bullshit though,
they don't really have much of a science
background and they're just.
They're just.
There also been a certain way I can buy
three things.
I tried to stick as close as I could to
the ketogenic diet,
but it probably wasn't a ketogenic diet
was just basically making sure that I
wasn't eating any sugar,
any fruit,
any carbs that I know that I know of.
I was eating within a 10 hour window,
so if I got up at 10:00
AM and I had anything to eat,
I didn't eat anything after eight and I
was trying to work out,
you know,
do something for an hour a day.
That's a,
well,
that's a great combination of mostly key
to genic or ketogenic and this,
um,
the fasting,
what you're doing is intermittent
fasting by going 14 hours every day
without eating.
That apparently is a really good
protocol for losing weight.
And I've done it.
I like it.
I think it makes me feel good to me.
Puts your body in a good place.
Your body gets accustomed to only eating
for eight hours a day and then the other
hours you just don't eat just normal
six,
16 hours.
You just know eating.
That's a tough one for most people it
is.
But especially on the road,
I'm like,
I'm having to eat after I perform and
it's like,
oh,
that means I can't eat until the
afternoon.
I don't fuck with it on the road,
on the road.
The most important thing to me is a
nutrition.
We're sleep and recovery,
sleep and exercise.
If I don't exercise when I'm on the
road,
I get off because uh,
you know,
the flying and everything,
I feel like your body needs to exert in
order to release endorphins and sorta
like that's why as soon as I walked in
the door here,
I grabbed the Kettlebell because I just
haven't been able to do any of that
stuff for a minute.
And so I've been here,
been in basically on my back for the
last three days.
I got some weird stomach thing or don't
have a bad piece of baked brie or
something and like knives and my stomach
for two days.
I was a dowery blaming on cheese.
I'm blaming it on.
I was going to blame it on you,
but I just got here though.
You can't blame it on code js code pay
for Bri.
I'm going to talk to bake bread again
today.
Are you one of those raw cheese guys?
Do you prefer the raw cheese?
Um,
I like,
I like cheese.
I try not to eat a lot of it just
because again,
anything that's too much of anything is
too much.
So yeah,
I agree.
But what I've found is that raw milk and
raw cheese in particular,
both those things,
I seem to digest them way easier than I
do the pasteurized and homogenized
first.
I mean,
but are you,
how are you getting it?
Are you getting it?
I actually have that in the US because
you can get raw cheese at whole foods.
There's so many.
Yeah.
Can get the foreign.
But like they actually making cheese in
the US.
It's a good question.
Is an awful hurdle.
Like.
Yeah,
because they want you to pasteurize
everything.
Like cheese in the US isn't nearly as
wonderful and tasty is that is a firm in
your cs just because of all the process
that you've had,
like raw
stuff from a farm and go check it out.
Dude.
I have burrata cheese in Italy and I was
like,
how do I get this home?
You don't.
You move to Italy,
you don't.
Could you even take Berata on an
airplane?
Would they let you.
They might not write,
smuggle it.
Well,
I had a friend who was French and he
came picturing right now,
right little little balloon.
I had a friend who was French from
France and he had to hide his cheese
because he had raw cheese.
He had a hide it in his luggage,
so you have to like folded up inside his
pants.
Like these bricks have wheels of cheese.
He had to like put his parents are
stuffed in his luggage to hide cheese.
They make it back and she's made it back
in.
Yeah,
he was his name and his address.
I can't tell you can't tell you.
He actually moved back to France.
He's like,
fuck this place.
But when he lived here they used to make
this raw cheese and like charcuterie
plate.
They would like cook raw cheese,
melted on the different smoked meats and
Oh,
I forget the name of it,
the name of the dish.
But it was sensational and they would
eat it with like Sauerkraut,
the art of eating you out of eating and
food to real art.
Right?
Yeah.
I think the trick when you get into
that,
you start getting into that gluttonous,
a activity with your,
with your,
with your world eeo.
It's the moderation part because you get
caught up in like Morris better and
cramming it in and just being able to
slow down and actually enjoy those
experiences without just,
without going full blown.
Gerard,
you put,
if he put like a plate of prosciutto in
front of me,
I'm fucked for a week because I'll eat
all of it.
I to.
Yeah,
I eat that stuff a lot because it's,
it's healthy.
It's like if you get like real good,
naturally cured,
you get lots of healthy fats from it.
So it's a great way to get a little
package of protein.
You know,
you just open it up and dig in there.
That's a good key to genic snack.
I did that one.
Yeah.
I always recommend MERC systems book the
primal blueprint and he's the guy though
that came on the podcast and apparently
he's incorrect about some wine stuff and
I was wondering.
Yeah,
what did he say he sending?
Talking about Kevin Vernon
wine and he made some mistakes.
Right?
Well,
I think there's a lot of misconceptions
about winemaking,
commercial,
large scale.
Why making.
I've seen a lot of things happen in
sellers,
large scale sellers that are cutting
corners.
It's just a lot of things that they have
to do,
but there's this idea that there's all
these things that we're adding to our,
to our wines,
give you headaches and fuck you up.
So in,
you know,
in our vineyard we do have copper sprays
and things that are kind of a,
we're avoiding a frost or we're avoiding
bunch rot.
A copper sprays.
Yeah.
It's,
yeah,
it's a long story.
Um,
but you know,
it's organic stuff we're trying to do to
address the actual copper.
Uh,
I'm not sure if it's actual copper or
not.
I would imagine it's no.
Huh?
I don't know.
Okay.
I don't know the answer to that,
but that's just something that you're
doing in the,
in the vineyard that are kind of like a
organic practices that are acceptable,
but one of the things when the fruit
actually gets to the winery,
uh,
I'm inoculating it with a,
a pro,
a packaged yeast,
so something that might be an isolate is
trained from Barolo or from Tuscany.
Uh,
but other than that,
at the end of the process,
we'll add a kms and so to solution to,
to stabilize the wine,
to keep it bottled with safe in the
bottle.
But what does kms stand for?
Sulfur where we actually were salt.
We're adding sulfites to the wine,
but wine itself actually produces.
Those byproducts were just,
were just escalating it to make sure
that this wine can make it on a truck to
New Jersey or to whatever and they blow
off that go away.
So that's A.
Yeah.
Basically just kind of preserves it.
And some places that are paranoid about
where that wine is going and how long
it's going to be sitting in a truck.
And maybe it's not going to be
refrigerated.
They're probably adding a little bit too
much and there's some places that are
actually adding,
you know,
other weird stuff,
enzymes and stuff into their wines and
in the process.
But in my cellar it's basically,
it's the yeast holes,
it's the,
it's the yeast and at the end it's
[inaudible].
We're not doing any other weird added.
Oh.
So the idea that there's like all these
chemicals and all these extra things
were jamming and do our wines is
ridiculous.
So it's just a misconception.
I think so.
Yeah.
I mean,
but are there any wine companies that do
that?
I'm sure,
yeah.
There's a lot of stuff.
People that are adding,
you know,
they're adding a,
what they call mega purple.
They're adding like tannins and they're
adding color and the wood is,
oh,
so adding like weird nutrients on this
end and wording,
you know,
while we have nutrients on that end and
some nitrogen on this end,
they're,
you know,
they're adding a lot of extra stuff in
the process that,
you know,
I don't do it because we're doing very
small batches of things and then they
don't have to alert people what they're
putting in either.
I mean,
it's just wine.
You get a bottle one,
you assume it's just wine.
Yeah.
Um,
I think that's changing.
I think the FDA's threatening to stick
their nose into,
uh,
into wineries now,
which is a pain in the ass,
you know,
they want to know where everything's
coming from and going to and really all
the shit that's going on.
You can deal with a group over move
books.
The one.
Yeah,
we're going to moon pool.
So for you're new,
you're just doing for the last 3000
years they were adding husks.
Bookton ruin the diva.
What husks we're.
Yeah.
So,
um,
so when you're,
when you're adding the stuff to the wine
and you say that it burns off like
you're adding sulfites are sulfate
sulfur softening software just as a,
as a preserve,
is there
an ideal?
Was off I should say?
Okay.
When you bottle of wine,
is there an ideal time after you borrow
that wine where it should be consumed?
Um,
I mean you can bottle it the minute you
can open up to the minute it's bottle if
you want to,
if you want to open it up.
But this era,
where does the,
like when we drank that wind from like
19,
24 or whatever the fuck it was that good
or is that different?
I mean it's like
it's all good wine.
This is a long conversation,
but you know,
winds in theory,
there's places that,
that just the natural structure of that
place,
the Ph,
the asset balances of those places and
depending on how well or not.
Well,
the wine maker got out of the way to
make sure that,
that one,
that wine made it into a bottle.
It was proper,
uh,
the,
the storage of it.
The,
the Cork,
how that,
how that went.
There's so many,
so many,
so many variables,
but when you're talking about the track
record of a particular site and a
producer,
um,
there are,
you know,
there are wines that you just expect.
If I'm going to buy this Latour,
I'm going to buy a this fine burgundy.
You expected that wine has been held to
a standard for a long period of time,
like all throughout decades,
millennia,
uh,
they have been consistent.
So you expect that I should be able to
lay this wind down for 50 years and it
should be okay.
It'll be different in 50 years.
I'm provided none of those other
variables.
Like somebody didn't pull it out and
leave it on the counter in the sun for a
week and then put it back on the seller
and 50 years later you open it.
It's crap all would take off.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's the heater sun itself.
It could be cold,
it could be something that goes to,
gets too cold,
it gets too dry.
The cork dries out.
It leaks that oxygen gets in a heat.
Is your enemy is your enemy oxygen as
your enemy,
so as long as it's treated correctly,
it could last a long time and it'll just
change and
it'll,
yeah,
it'll evolve over time and it will,
there's definitely an art to it.
There's like,
there's definitely like,
okay,
that,
that particular wine was ready to.
There's a peak,
that's the shadow,
drank it.
Right.
Then
how do you know,
do you know from reading like articles
or
again,
it's,
you know,
it's some,
that's why I buy some guys buy a case or
two cases of wine that they know they're
going to like and they're trying them
over time and they're figuring it out
and then they'll have that wine and
they'll go,
hey guys,
I just had a,
the 10th bottle of wine from those 24
bottles and it's starting to go over the
hill.
So there's a little forum or somebody to
call on each other back and forth going,
hey,
I think this particular wine is,
is,
has seen its best day.
Uh,
and they'll get back online and somebody
will go,
no,
mine's fire.
You know,
the arguments about that.
But generally speaking,
it's that communication of guys saying
that's interesting.
So it requires like a community of
knowledgeable people to communicate
about it.
Yeah.
I have a buddy of mine,
he's a fucking total wine,
not invited me to his birthday party and
it was a wine tasting birthday party and
they were all sitting around like.
And they would judge the wine
afterwards.
It's very oaky.
There's hints of Tannin and I'd be like,
what in the fuck are you guys take?
And one of them that they didn't like
were like,
this one's corked.
I think this one's corked.
It was like,
this one's my favorite.
I really liked this one.
You tell me it's bad.
This is bad.
Like cows it bad.
Like how do you know it's bad?
It seems like it's corked.
Like do,
does that drive you crazy?
They're super busy.
So there's like a level of
pretentiousness that's acceptable.
Again,
everybody wants to kind,
trying find their way in life and try to
find what makes them better than,
or different than or separates them or
elevates them because pallets.
Amazing.
His Palette is incredible.
He's going to be able to tell when he
ties it and you get some fat ass.
Orson Welles dude sitting there.
Yeah.
If you know,
after a couple of classes,
if that thing's not really torqued,
I'm drinking it.
Yeah.
Right.
Especially after a couple of glasses.
In the olden days they used to drink
wine because water would go bad,
right?
Yeah.
The,
well the,
well still water sit around.
It would still water.
But also,
um,
you know,
if you have in this situation where you
have like,
you know,
like New Orleans complete devastation of
a,
of the water table.
There's like decomposing bodies
everywhere and you can't drink the
groundwater.
You can't trust what's coming out of
your.
Well,
you know,
um,
fermented fermented juice is what you
would drink if it's safe because it's
gone through fermentation process.
A process of purification,
just like vodka.
The water of life,
you know,
it's the water that doesn't freeze.
So you can go through the Tundra.
If you had an eat snow,
you're going to freeze to death.
If you try to like melt the snow,
you're building.
If you do have a fire but they actual
water of vodka doesn't freeze and you
can actually survive.
You have to have water while you're
walking through this frozen Tundra and
get the benefit of being drunk all the
time.
Drunk as fuck in a snowbank yeah.
Like Vikings had a big ass leather sack
full of wine.
There were always hammered.
Yeah.
No wonder why they had such a ridiculous
behavior.
They're drunk all the time.
She's eating mushrooms and Reagan made.
That's wind or that's what it's made out
of,
honey.
Yeah.
Honey.
Wine.
Beer.
Yeah.
Honeys a weird preservative.
Right?
Because it doesn't go bad ever.
Yeah,
I like it.
Hey,
you can take things in.
Honey.
You stuff.
I'm in honey and they just stay good.
They think that's one of the things that
led to the iphone five.
Is it work good on honey?
What do you mean?
Still preserved as looking at different.
You still use an iphone five.
You one of those guys.
That's the iphone six.
I'm just kidding,
but you have a,
you have a port for the headphones,
phone port.
So we stopped changing.
That's where we draw the line.
I draw the line and they had from port.
A lot of people do like that's where I
draw the line.
But uh,
so meade,
what,
like I'd read something where they were
speculating that one of the conversions
from mushroom culture to meed cause they
think that we used to be like our,
um,
the intoxicants.
We're primarily psychedelic and then
they went to alcohol,
some point in human history and that,
that might've coincided with people
trying to preserve mushrooms in honey
and that they produce some sort of a
honey mushroom chemical reaction that
the honey actually fermented.
Yeah.
And then people started drinking meat
and then meat culture changed the way
people,
alcohol culture,
which is like an aggressive,
you know,
loose,
losing inhibitions,
wild culture.
Is there any movement to bring back
those leather wind socks,
you know,
those.
What are those things called?
Those things that the um,
that went and the vikings had to carry
him around those leather sacks,
bladder,
the wind bladder.
Um,
any benefit to drinking,
I think I need you to roll in to
augustine wine bar with a fucking
bladder and a fucking horned helmets.
Right?
Drink your ale from one of the day as
bullhorn things.
Do they,
I mean,
does anybody,
um,
serve wine out of like a leather thing?
I would feel like that's like the next
Mumford and sons should be time to do
what they do.
Growler.
So if you're walking into a andover was
a beer bar,
I think there allow you to bring in,
if it's a measured out,
what that volume is and you can refill
your growler.
Uh,
with beer.
I think some places do the same with
wine.
Uh,
the big,
the big issue is,
is the labeling.
So like,
you know,
the ttp gets all weird and the liquor
department gets all weird because like,
well the bottle has all the labeling on
it that I need to make sure that you're,
are you pregnant because there's a
warning on here about that.
Um,
so if you're just coming in and filling
your growler with wine,
I think the assumption is that at some
point you,
you know,
violate the law.
Yeah.
I don't know or not.
I don't know.
It seems kind of weird to me.
Yeah,
just fill up.
Just let the Guy Philip is thing.
Have you ever thought about
experimenting with like a leather
bladder for your wine to see if it
influences the taste?
We did one for a,
not a leather one,
but did like a plastic one for um,
uh,
we do a wine garden.
What do you got there?
That's the,
that's the bladder on the range that
rock on the range.
We did it at um,
uh,
after aftershock we had like a wine.
I could ucs American wine booth.
We did one down in Florida for a couple
of festivals.
And does it affect the taste at all
being in that?
Yeah,
I mean,
well if you're in the middle of a field
with a bunch of shitty bands playing,
it's going to taste different.
You know,
it's hot and you're annoyed.
So yeah,
it's going to taste different.
Even drink it because you're annoyed and
do you have recommended temperatures
that your wine should be stored or
served that?
Yeah,
I mean just normal.
A normal seller,
a seller,
cellaring anyone.
That'd be nice if you could put it at
like 50 degrees and you're in your wine
cellar.
A good spot for it.
40 slash 40 slash $45.
That's what you want,
but you don't want to put in your fridge
because it's going to get too cold.
Well yeah,
if it's,
if you're going to drink it fairly right
away.
If you go to the store and you got to,
you're going to get a bottle of wine.
You want to cram in the fridge for the
day to open it up that night,
that's fine.
But if you store your wine in the
fridge,
that's a little too cold.
Oh,
be storing it.
I've done that before.
But it's better than leaving it out in,
on top of your fish.
Court's going to get baked.
So it's Kinda like way out.
Your House is 70 degrees.
It shouldn't just leave it in your
house.
Um,
you can,
as long as it's going to maintain 70
supermarket though,
and they have those,
like it's all sitting there and yeah,
they're not doing anything about that.
Are you buying wine at a supermarket?
I don't know where else spa or should I
go?
A nice wine shop that's gonna.
So pretentious.
It's like going on a cigar bars dealing
with those guys.
Same thing.
It's like it's from Nicaragua.
Smelled the Secar Niqab.
Well,
this producer uses a lot of natural
fermentation and they,
you know,
they definitely do it,
we worked and like Baba Blah Blah dorks
baseball card dorks.
The same person.
Yeah.
I'm just going after wines.
The baseball cards can.
I just had the fucking give me.
They give me a nigger.
Mandela and a lime and a bag of chips
were good.
Model is a good one.
Oh good.
What do you.
A bag of lime and chips?
The lime?
A little lime juice.
And then the Magellan.
A bag of chips.
Woo.
Yeah,
under Maduro.
Like a dark cigar for the snack.
Let's do this.
Okay.
Get yourself some shadow.
Nice.
What is that?
A pork rinds.
Oh,
okay.
Whew.
Pork rinds.
Luck.
I'm at a gas station.
A little bit,
a little bit of a sour cream,
a little bit of Valentino.
A hot sauce on that.
Oh,
it got cold.
You got he.
He got crunch.
You got salt.
You got sweet from the cream.
Now you one of those guys that will not
drink a red wine with fish.
I'll drink.
I don't.
Yeah,
I'll,
I'll.
I don't abide by those rules.
I've had red wines that go with all
things in white wines ago and rosaries
that go with all things.
I'll try all of them,
but if the,
if,
if the experience isn't working,
I'll shift gears,
but I won't be afraid of.
I won't,
I won't be afraid.
I won't go with a set rule going in.
They used to be a hard fast rule,
right?
Wasn't kind of.
Yeah,
in general,
I think it's more,
it's just more,
it's just more of something to talk
about at the grocery store,
so it's like a fetish I'm having.
I'm having this for dinner.
What should I have?
I think a red wine pairing.
Yeah.
Good parents here are these some,
some restaurants have a pairing with
each selection and very rarely do you
have a white wine with a bloody steak.
I do.
I'll do it.
It's crazy.
Have you lived
on the edge though?
I'm on the edge.
You're out there right on the edge of
the earth where it goes off.
Did we did a three hours already?
It's already gone by.
All right.
No,
that's.
Yeah,
it's pretty crazy.
How the fuck does that happen?
Got a workout in whenever you're in.
Did your stretch you things in the back
there?
Oh,
did you know that thing with the back
things?
Amazing.
Yeah,
I didn't do that.
I didn't do the one with the weights.
I just did the one me hanging upside
down.
Will.
I'll show it to you after we're done
with us.
The things,
the shit.
Yeah.
Everybody should have one of those just
for back maintenance.
That's Goddamn epic.
It just looks like it had too much
weight on it.
No,
it's,
it's not that heavy.
It seems like it,
but it's like a perfect union of
contrary things available.
Now,
ladies and gentlemen,
I suggest you go out and purchase it
immediately.
We did a top Ten New York Times best
seller.
Let's see what we can get this bitch up
to.
Number One,
ladies and gentlemen,
come on.
Don't go buy it.
You know,
it's good.
He's wearing a wig.
A merkin come out.
Always a pleasure,
my brother,
sir.
Thank you.
Always.
Awesome.
Mm.